[Musique]
bien bonjour bonjour à tous
merci merci d'être à nos côtés l'autre
côté de la caméra donc nous entamons
aujourd'hui notre douzième et dernière
convention avant avant l'été on a fini
par le sujet de la santé ça n'est pas ça
n'est pas par hasard il y a ça fait
maintenant 18 mois convient les uns les
autres au rythme du duc au vide
cette situation sanitaire inconnue avec
les conséquences que ça pue avoir
d'abord bien évidemment sur le plan
sanitaire c'est la première des choses
mais aussi sur le plan économique sur le
plan sur le plan social nous a amenés
comme pour chacune de nos conventions à
faire un gros travail de fond avec une
mobilisation très importante de à la
fois de nos parlementaires de nos élus
mais au-delà de cela
beaucoup d'experts qui nous ont qui nous
ont rejoints et accompagner dans nos
travaux de réflexion on est parti d'un
constat qui était le suivant sur une
gestion de cette pandémie par l'état ou
où l'état a été a été défaillant sur un
certain nombre de points donc il ya une
partie critique mais surtout une partie
opposition c'est ça l'essentiel
on va et venir dans dans quelques
instants avec annie d'helmand notre
sénatrice qui suit les sujets de santé
entre autres mais ensuite d'autres aussi
au sénat jean pierre door député qui
toujours été celui qui a qui est
intervenu qui était notre fer de lance
j'ose dire depuis des années sur les
sujets santé et puis hein
d'autres intervenants qu'on va vous
présenter dans dans quelques instants
avec et bien entendu professeur philippe
juvin qui au-delà d'être élu membre de
la direction s'est beaucoup impliqué
dans ces sujets de santé ce qui est
ressorti sur la traversée de cette crise
depuis depuis 18 mois
c'est une gestion de l'état à céret
erratiques c'est à dire que ça a été
bien souvent au coup par coup
on a très souvent eu un un temps d'un
temps de retard ça s'est senti ça s'est
senti d'abord parce que
tout le monde a compris qu'ils n'avaient
pas de on a manqué de vision stratégique
l'état a manqué de vision stratégique
pour aborder cette pandémie on a une
gestion très centralisé on l'a vu à
maintes reprise bien souvent
technocratique bureaucratique avec une
france qui s'est découvert très
dépendante dépendantes sur les
médicaments sur les jeux revient pas sur
les masques sur les tests sur les
respirateurs sur tous ces sujets et
parallèlement à cela des collectivités
territoriales qui dans cette période se
sont révélés
agile réactive on l'a vu là aussi sur
sur les tests sur les masques sur la
l'organisation de la vaccination
également un personnel de santé qui
était remarquable extraordinaire ces
moments avec une mobilisation sans
faille mais bien souvent un peu un peu
perdu par effectivement ce manque de
vision stratégique c'est ça qui nous
amène aujourd'hui à refonder et à
réfléchir à la refondation complète de
notre système de santé tout d'abord
d'avoir une vraie vision sur notre
système de santé qui doit reposer sur la
prévention sur l'innovation sur la
réactivité tout ce qui nous a manqué
dans cette période et c'est sur cette
base là que nos élus et tous nos experts
nous on nous aura accompagnés nous ont
aidé et je pense bien sûr frédéric
bizarre économistes mais aussi président
de l'institut de santé qui a porté une
réflexion nouvelle mais il va nous la
faire partager tout à l'heure avec jean
paul ortiz président de la confédération
des syndicats médicaux qui lui aussi va
apporter non seulement son témoignage
mais aussi l'analyse qu'il fait de cette
vision de la vision qui devrait être la
nôtre pardon et puis c'est à partir de
ce travail qu'on va vous présenter au
fur et à mesure des débats que l'on va
avoir une série de propositions très
concrètes qui s'appuie sur ses sur ces
enjeux il faut tirer les conséquences de
sa nous l'avons fait dans bien d'autres
dans bien d'autres domaines sur les 11
conventions qui ont précédé on est parti
à chaque fois de la même
j'ai de la même méthode de travail
c'est-à-dire un constat à constat qu'il
faut partager
une fois qu'on a partagé ce constat on
en tire une analyse et on vient
seulement après aux propositions donc je
vais pas vous en dire davantage
maintenant tout de suite laissé la
parole à annie d'helmand et puis après à
jean pierre door et ensuite je les
laissais tous les deux organiser ce
débat
et puis et bien on vous présentera aussi
tout à l'heure nos propositions en les
étayant ses en expliquant pourquoi on
arrivait à ses propositions ça n'est pas
le fait du hasard c'est justement le
fait de toutes ces consultations et des
témoignages que l'on a pu reconnaître et
puis des failles aussi en se comparant
avec avec nos voisins parce que
l'intérêt dans ce genre de choses c'est
on peut pas la france peut pas avoir une
vision seul il faut aussi s'enrichir des
erreurs mais aussi des réussites de nos
voisins avec une part importante je n'ai
pas évoqué dans le constat mais sur
l'innovation
il faut comme dans beaucoup de domaines
laisser la place à l'innovation à
l'action à la recherche
on ne doit pas s'enfermer et on l'a sans
doute trophée s'enfermer dans dans des
méthodes et dans des analyses qui
n'était pas adapté à réagir une telle à
une telle pandémie
annie allez je te laisse démarrer merci
chers question ben je salue aussi tous
les participants et les internautes qui
nous regardent comme tu l'as dit notre
famille politique et engagé un travail
d'ampleur pour l'organisation de ces
forums thématiques et des conventions
j'en profite pour remercier à nouveau
pour avoir permis et garantit la
continuité de nos travaux des travaux
que nous avons engagées je pense que
cette convention nationale aura une
ambiance un peu particulière par rapport
à celles qui ont été qui sont déjà
déroulées eu égard au contexte sanitaire
bien sûr que nous connaissons et que
nous subissons tous malheureusement
sans polémiquer sur la gestion de la
crise sanitaire
nos collègues élus et nous mêmes avons
eu largement le temps et l'occasion
d'exprimer nos réserves sur quant aux
décisions qui ont été prises et qui
seront prises à nouveau par le
gouvernement nous ne pouvons
malheureusement constater les effets set
ça cette crise a exacerbé les
dysfonctionnements de l'organisation
notre système de santé et les grandes
difficultés que rencontrent les
personnels soignants qu'il soit à la
ville à l'hôpital dans les
établissements sociaux ou médico-sociaux
tout y est avec cette crise le manque de
moyens humains et matériels
la communication qui est difficile entre
les administratifs et les soignants le
manque de considération financière aussi
des personnels soignants
le passage au second plan de la médecine
de ville
le manque de coordination entre le
public et le secteur privé
et bien sûr le grand retard dont les
soignant et les patients souffrent dans
l'accès à l'innovation en ce qui
concerne notre souveraineté sanitaire
nos capacités de réaction face à
l'urgence et aux besoins d'innovation
je pense que la question du vaccin a été
un sacré révélateur c'est donc à travail
de deux ans nous avons mené il s'est
fondé sur le réel sur les expériences de
terrain et avait deux objectifs d'abord
comme tu l'as dit les constats nous
avons pu dresser grâce à nos échanges
avec les médecins les personnels
médicaux paramédicaux dix chercheurs
les économistes de la santé comme
frédéric bizarres des responsables
administratifs des directeurs de
laboratoires pharmaceutiques et une
réflexion commune est unanime a montré
la nécessité d'un gros travail de
refondation qu'il est impératif de mener
rapidement pour revitaliser notre
système de santé
le second objectif était bien sûr de
faire émerger des propositions concrètes
à la lumière de ce constat et les
propositions d'actions nous avons
décliné sur trois axes et que nous
allons vous présenter durant ce temps
des changes porte une ambition forte
pour la france redonner les moyens à
notre pays d'assurer un accès à des
soins de haute qualité pour les français
je pense que maintenant j'ai passé la
parole à jean pierre door merci annie de
ces paroles je voudrais remercier
christian jacob
notre président d'avoir mis à l'ordre du
jour la convention santé dans les
conventions de notre mouvement politique
c'était très important d'avoir ce sujet
au cours de la douzaine des conventions
qui se sont déroulées depuis 18 mois
bien entendu hier on enviait les
français enviait notre système de santé
c'était pour eux le meilleur sans le
système de santé
quasiment presque système de santé au
monde
aujourd'hui malheureusement il au bord
de la rupture il est il va dans le mur
c'est ce que l'on dit tous les jours
régulièrement sur le plan de
l'organisation sur le plan des
structures mais également sur le plan
financier
les médecins sont désenchantés les
personnels hospitaliers sont à bout les
patients ne trouve plus du tout la
possibilité à qui se confier l'accès aux
soins devient de plus en plus difficile
que ce soit à la campagne dans les
territoires ruraux mais également en
ville
et pourtant les français ne veulent pas
aller se faire soigner ailleurs
ils font confiance à moitié à demi mots
et tous mettent en haut du tableau le
sujet de la santé dans leurs propres
préoccupations
et on le voit d'ailleurs dans les sujets
au moment de des élections régionales et
départementales ou la santé occupe
effectivement une des premières places
pour nos candidats
en dépit des lois successives qui se
sont intéressés à notre système de santé
il y a eu notre système de soin il y a
eu nos contraintes budgétaires qui ont
été débattus à plusieurs reprises chaque
année mais chacun y va de ses propres
solutions
mais le résultat finalement il est très
loin du compte
pourtant on investit dans la protection
sociale quasiment presque 700 milliards
d'euros par an c'est presque 33 % du pib
alors que nos voisins allemands à
proximité ont six ou sept points de
moins d'investissements dans cette
protection sociale alors nous avons cru
avec toute cette tout cela est rare mais
être armé contre tous les risques
sanitaires et on le voit très bien
aujourd'hui malheureusement avec ce
problème des épidémies et il faut
déchanter
alors les républicains veulent s'atteler
à la doubler caution premièrement bien
et mieux soigner et deuxièmement bien et
mieux dépenser car on ne fait pas de
médecine sans les médecins on le fera
jamais de médecine sans les
établissements privés comme les sens les
établissements publics et sans les
paramédicaux voilà je vous remercie et
ali maintenant je te passe la parole
pour présenter nos invités merci jean
pierre donc je vais présenter plaisir de
présenter
frédéric bizarre cher frédéric vous êtes
un économiste de la santé spécialisés
dans les questions liées à la protection
sociale et vous êtes d'ailleurs experts
sur ces questions près du sénat vous
enseignez également l'économie à la cp
business school et sciences po paris
votre expertise est considéré comme une
référence en france et vous publier de
nombreux travaux et ouvrages du qualité
reconnue sur l'économie de la santé
c'est d'ailleurs dans cette perspective
que vous avez fondé l'institut santé en
2018 qui est un signe temps dédié
aux réflexions autour de la réforme du
système de santé
votre expertise et vos multiples
contributions à nos travaux nous ont
d'ailleurs été très précieuse et nous
sommes tous très heureux aujourd'hui de
vous recevoir dans notre convention
santé à la suite de votre avoue que nous
avons suivi avec un grand intérêt
vous avez participé aux auditions de
notre groupe de travail vous avez publié
en 2010 neuf passages où les mets déjà
dit le livre sur la réforme de la santé
mais pouvez vous nous dire quels sont
les constats que vous faites de notre
système de santé et qui vous amène à la
nécessité de sa formation
quels sont les enjeux merci au groupe
les républicains sont présents christian
jacob de m'inviter c'est évidemment avec
beaucoup de plaisir que je suis là
puisque on essaie modestement de
contribuer à la refonte de systèmes à le
penser c'est un système extrêmement
complexe qui peut redevenir le meilleur
au monde sous conditions so condition
qu'on le canton leur structure le fond
en comble alors première chose sûre je
me permettrai pas de porter la moindre
critique sur le programme temps je
connais la difficulté de réfléchir sur
le fond et je peux encore une fois que
féliciter ceux qui l'ont fait parce que
c'est très rare c'est une des premières
fois qu'on réfléchisse sur le fond du
système de la réforme du système de
santé en tout cas j'ai passé plus de
temps à l'étranger qu'en france dans ma
vie professionnelle mais en tout cas
j'ai pas de souvenir de ça donc ça c'est
quelque chose et je suis pas sûr mais là
je n'ai pas de respect politique mais je
je je navigue pas mal je ne suis pas sûr
qu'ils aient d'autres réflexions
la deuxième chose c'est comme l'a dit
très gentiment finalement qu'en plus
j'ai moi même contribué depuis trois ans
à essayer de reforger une pensée autour
du nouveau système de santé qu'il faut
impliquer avec une centaine de personnes
aujourd'hui on a sorti un ouvrage je
dirais il ya un an et demi un rapport
intermédiaire on va sortir le rapport
définitif à la rentrée donc là aussi je
connais toutes les difficultés
je pense qu'il sait plus tellement la
peine de justifier la raison pour
laquelle il faut repenser le système ou
alors si à la prochaine élection
présidentielle on a encore des candidats
qui disent on a le meilleur système de
santé donc laissé circulez ya rien à
voir je pense qu aura pas beaucoup de
crédibilité en revanche encore une fois
le risque c'est qu'on est comme
d'habitude plutôt des des mesures non
structurantes et qui finalement laisse
le modèle principalement tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui
comme je n'ai que plus que huit minutes
maintenant je vais pas brassé je vais
pas brassé l'ensemble du système de
santé je vais prendre un aspect qui
manque peut-être dans ce que j'ai pu
lire mais c'est pas trop tard parce que
c'est vraiment l'aspect le plus
politique de la santé et la grande
difficulté de la santé c'est que vous
responsables politiques
vous ne faites pas de politique avec la
santé vous faites de la technique vous
essayez de dire comment est ce qu'on
peut améliorer les hôpitaux
comment est ce qu'on peut améliorer la
médecine de ville comment est ce qu'on
peut et ça c'est pas de la politique de
santé sas et l'amélioration d'une
composante du système
la clé de la réforme la politique de
santé comme d'ailleurs de la plupart des
systèmes socio économique
c'est la gouvernance la crise de système
elle est à plusieurs il ya plusieurs
facteurs plusieurs facettes plusieurs
têtes mais la crise de la crise c'est
une crise de la gouvernance d'accor on a
comme dans un parti politique
si vous avez une gouvernance défaillante
on sait bien que derrière ça entraîne
tout un tas de désorganisation de
failles et d'inefficacité qui décide de
quoi qui a le pouvoir sur qui c'est tout
ça qui a complètement failli dans la
crise sanitaire mais qui faillit depuis
des années il ya une crise a été dit par
le président une crise de l'état et je
la generali seraient pas à toute la
à toutes les fonctions de l'état peut
penser que bercy par exemple a bien
fonctionné pendant sept ans dans cette
crise mais là le ministère de la santé
comme le ministère de la recherche
ou comme le ministère de l'industrie il
n'y a pas de pilote dans l'avion
le seul pilote c'est la haute fonction
publique
donc vous n'avez aucune vision politique
et vous pouvez prendre mettre les
ministres les uns après les autres c'est
rien de jeu aucune critique sur les
ministres actuels fait comme les autres
il laisse la haute a dit fait de la
communication il est la haute
l'administration qui fait ce qu'elle
sait faire c'est géré principalement
comptablement et principalement
administrativement on peut pas lui jeter
la pierre c'est comme ça qu'elle
fonctionne donc vous n'avez aucune
vision politique présente et à venir
le ministre de la santé n'a quasiment
aucun poids politique pour le coup on
l'a vu pendant la crise encore une fois
quelle que soit la personne que vous y
mettez je crois qu'il est numéro 14 dans
le dans l'ordre du gouvernement
est ce qu'on continue ça est-ce que
c'est adapté à ce qu'on a pu voir de
cette crise la place de la santé dans la
société que l'on a toujours considéré
évidemment comme un coup comme un coût
social comme une protection sociale
qu'il fallait dont il fallait plutôt
maîtrisée des coûts que développer quoi
que ce soit c'est ça la santé en france
depuis 20 ans jamais on se plaint que
l'industrie n'y a pas d'industrie de
santé qui par l'industrie de la santé
ça nous parle depuis 20 ans donc cette
déchéance à la fois globale du service
des produits de santé pas parler de
santé publique a quasiment jamais une
politique santé publique mais elle est
quand même le résultat de tout ça donc
est-ce qu'on laisse la gouvernance du
système comme elle est aujourd'hui non
donc il ya évidemment une réforme de
l'état en matière du pilotage de la
santé qu'il faut qu'il faut revoir
donner quelques quelques mois après il
ya aussi une réforme de l'ensemble des
composantes je parle toujours de la
gouvernance il est évident que si
l'hôpital est défaillante sa gouvernance
est complètement défaillant il ya que
les directeurs d'hôpitaux qui pense que
l'hôpital
enfin pas trop mal c'est encore une
conférence il ya plus c'était assez
extra l'un des grands chu directeur
d'hôpital
mais arrêtez ça va pas si mal donc la
gouvernance hospitalière ne peut pas
permettre à l'hôpital de bien
fonctionner la gouvernance de la
pratique des soins qui n'a jamais été
pensé
la gouvernance des professionnels de
santé est resté comme elle était en 45
par un conseil de l'ordre qui ne
gouverne que par une chose qui est la
déontologie enfin il ya un peu d'eau qui
a coulé sous les ponts il ya un peu de
deux d'innovation ça a été dit auteur
qui est arrivé la gouvernance des
pratiques on en est où nulle part et qui
doit le faire à quelques idées là-dessus
la gouvernance de la santé publique
si on a été obligé de créer tous ces
machins de comité scientifique de
monsieur vaccin de madame je ne sais
quoi c'est bien parce que on a un vrai
problème
alors qu'on en manque pas d'âge ans il
ya une multitude d'agents ce la haute
autorité de santé le conseil de santé
publique le haut conseil de l'avenir de
l'assurance maladie en a pléthore
mais on voit bien que tout ça est
totalement désorganisée parce qu'en fait
il n'y a pas de vision politique et ça
c'est pas un médecin c'est pas un
économiste c'est pas un citoyen lambda
c'est aux responsables politiques
d'imaginer dans le modèle de demain
comment va être piloté le prochain
système de santé salut c'est absolument
ya pas je veux dire deux mots sur nous
comme en cent dévoiler tout ce qu'on va
dévoiler à la rentrée mais pour vous
pour être dans le concret ça et c est
absolument capital parce que de la
gouvernance que vous allez choisir le
futur système de santé le modèle du
futur système de santé va dépendre si
vous voulez au lait au bout de
l'étatisation qui est en marche forcée
depuis 20 ans aller vers le modèle
britannique qui est le modèle étatique
par excellence si vous voulez fiscalisés
tout là tout le financement comme j'ai
pu l'entendre aller vers le système
britannique mais assumez les sauf que de
mon point de vue il est absolument pas
adaptée à la culture française parce
qu'un système de santé se ponce en
fonction d'un historique d'une culture
des valeurs d'accord c'est un modèle
utilitariste qui n'est pas basée sur
l'égalité des droits qui fait qu'il ya
un système public pour une partie de la
population un système privé pour une
autre je peux me tromper mais je pense
que c'est pas adapté si vous voulez
donner tout le pouvoir aux assureurs
privés aller vers un modèle américain il
faut l'assumer
si vous voulez continuer ses réseaux de
soins qui organise autant de systèmes de
santé qui a deux réseaux de soin et
d'assureurs privés aller vers le modèle
à l'américaine mais voyez bien que tout
ça c'est de la décision dans la
gouvernance dans la réorganisation de la
gouvernance puisque cette étatisation
sans élan sans vision moi je veux bien
qu'on et attise mai et alors que l'état
est une vraie vision soit capable de
piloter avec efficacité avec efficience
ce qui est évidemment pas du tout le cas
et c'est pas une question d'hommes vous
pouvez mettre dans le système actuel
n'importe qui c'est pour ça que moi je
suis prudent dans les dents les
critiques par rapport à la crise parce
que s'il ya une responsabilité
collective dans l'affaiblissement du
système
c'est une réalité sauf par contre ce
qu'on peut reprocher au gouvernement
c'est alors que la crise est quand même
comme disait churchill
on va pas gâcher une bonne crise c'est
que là il est en train de la gâcher
complètement puisque la seule chose qui
a été fait c'est de permettre de passer
la crise avec le ségur de la santé on a
remis sans aucun sens aucune recette à
côté on a définitivement tué le système
aujourd'hui ce qu'il est il est mort
financièrement système de santé morts ça
vous a pas échappé si vous projetez à 5
ans les comptes de la santé
vous vous êtes bien au delà de tout ce
qu'on a pu connaître y compris en 2009
et c'est structurel pas conjoncturel
donc de toutes façons le vous êtes
condamnés à transformer le système santé
juste pour cette raison pour finir
quelques éléments pour vous dire ok il
est gentil il dit mais donc qui ont fait
quoi pour un exemple le système de santé
est régulée principalement par quelque
chose qu'on appelle un projet de loi de
financement de sécurité sociale
je n'avais à mener mais je n'ai pas
trouvé amusez vous à regarder juste dix
pages et vous allez comprendre que c'est
pas sérieux que franchement c'est un
sérieux qu'on gère et même encore petit
familiale des congères les petites des
retraites sont des flux financiers
on a formé le système hockey enfin vous
avez le page en page 1
vous avez des tableaux avec les données
2019 cantate en 2020 et qu'il faut enfin
bref on gère ça comme si c'était des
flux financiers
c'est juste pas sérieux alors qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire si on veut repenser une
gouvernance d'abord l'état est
responsable selon moi mais je pense que
tout le monde ne partage de la stratégie
nationale de santé une stratégie
nationale de santé ça peut pas ce
médecin un grand professeur à côté de
moi ça peut pas se penser à un nom on
peut pas fixer des objectifs de santé
publique
il savait que mme buzyn qui pensaient
qu'ils allaient arrêter de faire arrêter
les français de fumer avec au bout de
trois ans en mettant le paquet de clopes
à 10 ans mais en plus souvent d'être
trop critique mais à peu près le seul
dans la critique face et tout ça n'est
pas sérieux ce n'est que de la com bon
donc il faut une stratégie à 5 ans
prenons le quinquennat avec des
objectifs de santé publique et avec une
loi de programmation sanitaires comme
vous avez dans la défense puisqu'on dit
c'est régalien la santé ce qui est vrai
pas tout la santé régaliennes mais il ya
une partie régaliennes qui est lié à la
protection de la population et cette
crise vient le rappeler
on voit bien que sa santé il n'y a pas
de liberté n'y a pas de sécurité donc ça
c'est le rôle de l'état et donc l'état a
quand même comme devoir de penser un
plan stratégique à cinq ans qu'ils
soient évidemment qui se transforme
parce qu'on est dans une démocratie par
une loi de programmation sanitaires à 5
ans qui comprend les objectifs le plan
d'action et le financement ce qui change
tout parce que là où tout d'un coup vous
donnez y compris aux industriels une
perspective des perspectives
d'investissement des choix
technologiques qui peuvent faire mais
bon ça peut-être pas passer à côté de la
reine message et si on avait fait ça bon
et évidemment comme ça ne vous empêche
pas d'avoir à voter une loi budgétaire
chaque année c'est une obligation
juridique qui de mon point de vue doit
sortir même si vous restez dans la sécu
mais qui ne doit pas être à mon avis
examiné mais enfin ça c'est plutôt du
détail avec les autres risques sociaux
parce qu'encore une fois la politique de
santé ça se résume pas à une politique
budgétaire mais il faut quand même être
capable d'en discuter de la débattre de
l'améliorer et de vérifier si on
on est bien dans la stratégie nationale
de santé bon deuxième réforme nécessaire
à mon avis et c'est l'organisation de
l'état s'il n'y a pas de politique de
santé c'est quand vous êtes ministre de
la santé
vous n'avez rien pour vous donner des
perspectives savait que le système de
santé actuel
il est piloté par rapport à l'offre en
fonction de l'offre on pilote pas des
besoins aux pilotes des professionnels
de santé des établissements de santé
c'est comme ça que dans les années 80 et
90 on s'est dit pour maîtriser la
dépense si on réduisait par deux la
démographie médicale
ce qu'on a fait pendant 15 ans donc il
est évident qu'il faut il faut passer à
une gestion d'une gestion de l'offre une
gestion de la demande de une gestion des
besoins mais encore faut-il avoir une
organisation de l'état qui permettent
d'évaluer de suivre l'évolution de ses
besoins
donc il faut une grande agence nationale
de santé publique mais qui se
substituent pardon à tout ce qui existe
c'est parce elle c'est pas une nouvelle
agence et qui donne des yeux qui donne
des jumelles à l'état pour que le
ministre de la santé puissent avoir une
vision claire et faire des choix
politiques
troisième idée ça sera la dernière
on parle beaucoup de en effet c'est tout
le système pas que de services mais met
industrielle qui part à vau l'eau
là aussi pour les mêmes raisons ont
regardé la gouvernance du médicament
il s'est juste un truc de vous vous avez
surtout qu'avec l' agence européenne
vous avez trois agences qui font à peu
près le même travail et c'est pas
bizarre qui le dit c'est ce qu'ils ont
dirigé l agence qui le dit puisqu'on
travaille avec tous ces gens là un entre
l'asm et la hs la comité comité comité
de transparence de la hm vous avez
exactement les mêmes analyses qui sont
fait de choix et on se dit mais c'est
pas normal on met 500 jours pour accéder
au marché en france contre 110 jours en
allemagne
enfin c'est la faute de qui ça s'est
quand même bien la faute de ceux qui
pilotent le système qui sont pas capable
de restructurer la gouvernance bon
voilà on peut comme ça à tirer le fil et
ça c'est vraiment de la politique de
santé
c'est vraiment aux politiques de décider
quel est le rôle de l'état est ce qu on
revient à une délégation comme je le
pense utile qui est au coeur du modèle
de 45 une délégation de service public
qui fait que l'état fait la stratégie
l'état est responsable des aspects
régalien de la santé mais délègue à une
démocratie sanitaire et sociale autour
de l'assurance maladie le pilotage
opérationnel du système ce qui fait que
par exemple les ars dont on dit ah mais
non mais faut arrêter critiqué jeudi que
les ars et l'état quel est le périmètre
de l'état faut les garder les ars mais
certainement pas avec ce périmètre là je
pense par exemple que les ars doivent
s'occuper de santé publique et de rien
d'autre parce que c'est le rôle de
l'état
je passe sur tous les aspects de
décentralisation qu'il faut si on veut
faire la santé publique
c'est très important et croyez moi c'est
complexe et ça aussi c'est très
politique que fait la région que fait le
département que fait la commune puisque
toutes ces politiques publiques qui agit
sur les déterminants de santé vous savez
qu'un système de soins n'est responsable
que de 20% de la population et de la
population
tout le reste c'est d'économique du
social du comportement individuel de
l'environnement bon donc il est évident
qu'il faut que toutes ces collectivités
territoriales si on veut optimiser
l'allocation des ressources comme on dit
il faut il faut les utiliser à fond
voilà donc en conclusion attention parce
qu'on sentait on a toujours le la
facilité de faire tout ce qui coûte cher
tout ce qui nécessite beaucoup de
dépenses et de surtout pas toucher à ce
qui a le plus d'impact et qui ne fait
que des économies et la réforme de la
gouvernance c'est ce qui aura le plus
d'impact et qui fera faire de beaucoup
d'économies donc voilà ne passons pas à
côté
excusez moi si j'étais trop long je
remercie merci frédéric busin jeu
mais je crois que beaucoup de
propositions vont aller dans votre sens
tout à l'heure je vais maintenant passer
la parole à philippe juvin cher philippe
christian a déjà présenté brièvement ton
parcours était fonction actuelle est
désormais les français ont un prix à te
connaître davantage cette dernière année
mais je vais quand même parler de tout
ce que tu représentes pour nous déjà et
pour ta ta municipalité était et est
administrée tué maire de la garenne
colombes et président de la fédération l
ère des hauts-de-seine député européen
jusqu'en 2019 tu es un médecin engagé
qui exercent au quotidien sur le terrain
comme chef de service aux urgences de
l'hôpital européen georges-pompidou jeu
tu arrêtes tu es régulièrement intervenu
dans les médias pendant la crise qu vide
moi je te remercie aussi parce que
heureusement ton calme et ton sens de
delà de la vérité on fait du bien
beaucoup de gens dans le marasme de
désinformation des informations qui
traînait un petit peu partout et
d'ailleurs j'ai ça ne m'a pas le titre
de ton livre je ne tromperai jamais leur
confiance m'a pas du tout étonné la
pandémique nous vivons encore
actuellement a mis au jour les failles
de notre système de santé et plus
particulièrement l'excès de
bureaucratisation elle technostructure
dans nos hôpitaux qui rend laborieuse
leur adaptation aux besoins des patients
peux tu nous présenter des constats et
des préconisations sur lesquels bien
évidemment nous reviendrons au moment de
la présentation de nos propositions
merci beaucoup a ni pour cette
présentation
merci d'abord à christian de m'avoir
invité à cette réunion qui est très
importante parce que c'est là qu'on voit
tout le
toute l'importance des partis politiques
des partis politiques c'est ça qui fait
que la société va s'améliorer parce que
les partis politiques travaillent et aux
républicains nous travaillons puisque je
crois que nous sommes un des seuls
partis politiques en france a essayé de
tirer les leçons de la crise sanitaire
des leçons qui sont à la fois sanitaire
et pas d'ailleurs sanitaires alors vous
m'avez demandé justement de partir du
constat de la crise est de savoir si on
pouvait à partir cette crise faire
quelques tirer des leçons et
éventuellement des débuts de
propositions tout d'abord moi je crois
tout à fait comme frédéric bizarre que
l'état n'a pas été la solution n'est pas
la solution est assez même parfois le
problème est que la solution c'est la
société ou vu directement 10 sur les
individus et on l'a vu dans cette crise
sont les individus qui ont tenu et la
cour des comptes a dit le système de
santé n'a pas tenu contrairement à ce
qu'on dit le système de santé à
improviser et évidemment la différence
est de taille
la première leçon je pense c'est 7 de
nos ressources nous sommes un pays qui
est appauvri et si on ne parle pas de
cette question fondamentale est bien
faut pas s'étonner qu'un jour on puisse
plus payer un système de santé tout
commence par là plus d'argent plus de
système de santé est en fait déjà nous
payons le fait que nous appauvrissons
dans les années 80 le pib par tête de
pipe en france était quasiment égal à
celui des etats unis enfin peu inférieur
mais presque égal
aujourd'hui on est à 28 % le moins donc
le pays s'est considérablement appauvrie
il faut pas donc s'étonner que le
système de santé ne soit pas le meilleur
du monde contrairement à ce que nous
disions comme l'a très bien rappelé
jean-pierre 85 % des nouveaux
médicaments sont disponibles en
allemagne 67% simplement des nouveaux
médicaments sont disponibles en france
c'est une conséquence directe de
l'appauvrissement donc de toute façon il
y aura pas de politique de santé
si celle ci n'entre pas dans le cadre
d'une politique qui permet une nouvelle
prospérité au pays
deuxième leçon c'est la question je
crois des moyens matériels et humains
c'est à dire que le système de santé est
devenu trop petit et on le voit n'ont
pas toutes les crises que vides
heureusement il y en a une tous les deux
par deux ou trois par siècle et à toutes
les crises de la grippe chaque année
nous des programmes ont des patients
chaque année lors des épidémies
les médecins de ville sont submergés et
chaque année on est étonné en fait on a
un système de santé qu'il soit à
l'hôpital ou en ville qui est trop petit
donc il faut former des il faut pour
s'informer des médecins il faut force à
former des professionnels de santé que
nous n'avons pas suffisamment il faut
inventer des parcours du patient il faut
inventer des délégations de tâches
alors c'est vrai on dit qu'on va le
faire depuis des années mais il est
temps qu'on le fasse et enfin on va
former des ip à des infirmiers
spécialisés
c'est une très bonne chose mais enfin je
veux dire je crois qu'on en a informé 40
l'année dernière donc ce n'est pas à la
hauteur des besoins de troisième leçon
je pense que c'est ce que vous disiez
tout à l'heure c'est la leçon
d'organisation nous souffrons trop de
bureaucratie les ordres et contre-ordres
les chefs les sous-chefs enfin tout ça
est absolument dingue
le conseil de l'ordre des médecins avait
calculé le nombre d'heures qu'un médecin
généraliste en ville devait consacrer je
retourne vers le président ortiz pour ce
qu'il en pense mais c'était de l'ordre
de 5 ou 6 heures par semaine donc on est
dans une dans une folie à l'hôpital
c'est pareil à l'hôpital et bien c'est
très simple administration fait bien son
travail elle organise des réunions et
l'organiser réunion avec nous et donc
nous ça nous prend du temps pour le
travail etc etc
donc on a une vraie question
d'organisation je pense qu'il ya une
question d' évidemment de
territorialisation il ya des tas de
choses qui sont beaucoup mieux géré à
l'échelon des concentrés ou
décentralisée quel échelon centralisée
ça va de soi enfin ça peut pas être le
président de la république qui décide
combien de lits de réanimation il faut
combien de respirateurs on va commander
et combien de masse qu'on va commander
parce que c'est ça qu'on a vu jeu alors
on est dans une famille politique mon
cher question où la vème république est
un peu ça crée donc je vais faire très
attention à ce que je dis mais il ya un
livre de jean françois revel qui a 30
ans dont le titre est intéressant c'est
la 5ème république ou l'absolutisme
inefficace la thèse c'est que poussé à
l'extrême quand elles disent fonctionne
la république elle est tellement
centralisés dans les mains du président
qu'en fait elles ne fonctionnent pas et
on l'a vu dans la crise
autre leçon je crois que c'est la
question de l'innovation c'est simple
pour faire court la france a raté les
deux révolutions scientifiques de cette
crise la ra de messages et on est passé
à côté et le séquençage on en fait
toujours pas en france et donc la
question que nous devons avoir c'est
comment faire en sorte que nous ayons de
nouveau de l'innovation au niveau de la
recherche
et là il ya toute une politique à avoir
qui est une politique qui va
de la remise en cause de l'application
actuelle du principe de précaution et le
risque qu'il faut pas l'abolir il faut
simplement accepter le maîtriser c'est
aussi la question des sciences dans la
société moi je crois qu'on n'apprend
plus les sciences société dès le
primaire on a plus d'esprit scientifique
il n'y a pas de barda le barda c'est ce
fonds américain qui permet à l'industrie
de défense de financer des tas
d'activités industrielles et de
recherche et d'innovation et qui permet
aux états unis de voir fleurir et des
industries innovantes extraordinaire il
faut favoriser la recherche entre le
privé public c'est qu'aujourd'hui on
sait qu'en ce pas le virus
une des raisons pour laquelle on sait
qu'en se passer c'est que le public et
le privé ne travaillent pas ensemble
enfin tout ça est absolument fou et vous
parliez de la santé n'est qu'une dépense
immense en réalité elle peut être une
recette si elle avait une industrie de
santé innovantes qui permettrait de
conquérir le monde nous l'avons fait
dans le passé nous ne faisons plus
l'autre leçon je pense est peut-être la
plus importante c'est celle de la
confiance
un moment on a demandé au maire de séoul
en fait c'est le maire d'un des
districts de séoul et pourquoi ça a
marché chez vous vous aviez plus de
tests vous avez plus de l'hydre et
avouait plus de respirateurs et dit non
non vous n'avez pas compris chez nous
c'est la confiance qu un marché c'est à
dire qu'on faisait que les citoyens
faisaient conscient confiance aux
gouvernants et moi je crois qu'il faut
désormais acté que nous interdirons
l'utilisation du conseil de défense
comme un outil de pilotage de la santé
enfin c'est pas fait pour ça quand il ya
un comité scientifique qui ne publie pas
ses avis avant deux ou trois semaines ça
pose problème de transparence et je
crois que la transparence la confiance
c'est la condition absolue du fait que
les gens pourront participer à l'effort
quand il ya une crise comme ça et je
suis très favorable à l'utilisation des
outils de mesure de la performance j'ai
un peut l'expliquer qu'il faut mettre au
service de la transparence au service de
la performance et de la qualité
je donne un exemple il ya une fracture
très fréquentes qui est la fracture du
col du fémur
à partir d'un certain âge quand on tombe
on peut se cassé le col du fémur et bien
on sait que si on ne perd pas ces gens
avant 48 heures et une surmortalité il
ya une sur morbidité et bien demandons à
tous les établissements de santé public
privé de publier
le délai au bout duquel il opère la
fracture de hanche on n'impose rien vous
publiez le délai vous allez voir le
système va s'améliorer parce que la
transparence fait que naturellement les
systèmes s'améliore enfin je pense que
cette crise c'est aussi une grande leçon
sur l'humain au coeur de la santé on ne
veut plus des ehpad prison il faut tirer
une leçon de ces ehpad prison il faut
tirer une leçon du fait qu'en france on
a simplement 20 % des gens en fin de vie
qui ont besoin de soins palliatifs à
domicile qui ont effectivement accès
accès aux soins palliatifs et ça c'est
un enjeu qui est un enjeu quasi
civilisationnel la même manière je pense
que la priorité des priorités
aujourd'hui c'est de mettre en place un
plan d'urgence pour aller chercher tous
les patients qu'on n'a pas soigné depuis
un an parce que comprenons que on a
dégradé le système on a moins bien
soignés les gens parce qu'on était
submergé et aujourd'hui dans la nature
probablement fin il ya un travail qui a
montré que 50 % des maladies du coeur
des diabète les maladies psychiatriques
et probablement 30 à 40% des cancers au
mois de mars avril dernier n'ont pas été
diagnostiquées autrement dit sont dans
la nature en train de s'aggraver
il faut une stratégie pour aller
chercher ces gens là il est les sauver
puisqu'aujourd'hui un certain nombre
probablement ne sont pas traités et ni
diagnostic et donc c'est un sujet je
crois absolument majeur donc voila moi
si vous voulez je pense que
contrairement à ce que le gouvernement
chante matin midi et soir nous n'avons
pas bien géré la crise ont pour ceux qui
voudraient avoir quelques données il ya
l'institut molinari les gens très
sérieux
j'ai pas du tout à fait du républicain
donc tout va bien qui disent que qui ont
calculé les l'efficacité des politiques
en rapportant nombre de morts par
habitant par million d'habitants
rapportant à la diminution du pib donc à
la fois l'aspect économique et l'aspect
sauver des vies ben c'est simple il ya
des pays qui ont protégé les vies et
l'économie l'australie l'allemagne
il ya des pays qui ont bien protéger
leurs économies un peu moins bien leur
vie les etats unis les pays qui ont bien
protéger la vie de leurs concitoyens est
assez mal l'économie canada et puis il
ya des pays qui ont mal protéger leurs
économies plus de 5% de baisse du pib en
2020 et qui ont mal protéger leurs
populations parce qu'il est vrai
beaucoup de morts
belgique c'est la grande bretagne et
l'italie puis malheureusement c'est la
france moi je crois qu'il faut qu'on
apprenne de nos erreurs
ça a été un crash-test cette affaire
c'est un grand révélateur et il faut
faire il faut faire à partir de là le
constat qui a un nouveau système de
santé plus juste plus habiles plus
efficace plus innovant qu'il faut mettre
en place et c'est ça ce à quoi nous
devons servir aux républicains il y aura
des propositions aujourd'hui le
président jacob mais au fond les gens
pour être d'accord ou pas est ce que
nous voulons nous passer comme message
que ce qui est important ce n'est pas
tant d'être d'accord sur tout les
solutions 7 comprendre que nous avons
une colonne vertébrale et que nous
savons où nous allons et c'est ça je
crois là la grande leçon de cette crise
nous devons faire en sorte que tous ces
morts ce pas été des morts pour rien et
que le système de santé doit être
meilleur après qu'il ne l'était avant
merci
merci merci philippe de ces de ces
observations ont fait pas de médecine
sans les médecins
donc moi je suis très heureux de
recevoir ce soir jean paul ortiz qui est
médecin néphrologue qui est également le
président de la confédération des
syndicats français
des médecins premier syndicat qui
regroupe tous les médecins libéraux
généralistes et spécialistes
donc jean paul je connais depuis assez
longtemps pour savoir comment il traça
fait plus deux je crois dix ans qu'il
est à la présidence de ce syndicat va
lui poser des questions
quels sont les constats sur les failles
de notre système de santé qu'elles sont
aussi les propositions que vous feriez
pour relever les défis de la médecine de
ville
évidemment la grande question qui
intéresse les élus ceux qui nous
écoutent probablement ce soir y compris
tous les citoyens qui probablement nous
écoutent qu'elles sont il y à un manque
de médecins dans tous les territoires
qu'ils soient ruraux comme dans les
villes comme dans les villes
donc tous les citoyens s'intéressent à
cela c'est ce qu'ils ont fait leur
premier sujet d'intérêt quelles
solutions vous proposer à l'avenir je
pense que est-ce qu'il faut des
contraintes
est ce qu'il ne faut pas de contrainte
quelles seraient les conditions que vous
pourriez proposé pour que l'exercice de
la santé en france soit mieux répartie
dans notre système
ce sont des sujets majeurs et il faudra
en débat de ce soir
merci jean paul oui merci jean pierre de
m'avoir invité
cette convention des républicains je
suis là pour donner un peu là la vision
et la parole que les médecins libéraux
en tant que président de la
confédération des syndicats médicaux
français peuvent apporter
après cette crise du coleader je crois
qu'il faut tirer quelques enseignements
je reviendrai pas sur ce qui a été dit
précédemment parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
choses que je partage
je crois que nous avons par la crise uqo
vide
vu que notre système de santé était
extrêmement cloisonné très hospital au
centre et est malheureusement souffrais
d'une bureaucratie d'une gouvernance qui
n'étaient pas adéquates et de ce point
de vue là je partage en grande partie ce
qu'a dit tout à l'heure
frédéric bizarre parce qu'on voit bien
que l'état est à la fois régulateur de
l'offre de soins via les ars mais
quelque part aussi avec l'étatisation de
l'assurance maladie et la transformation
progressive et la mainmise de l'état sur
l'assurance maladie il est aussi le
payeur et les assureurs complémentaires
sont aujourd'hui pratiquement devenus
des assurances complémentaires quasiment
obligatoire donc on a complètement fait
évoluer notre système et la façon dont
s'était organisé alors je crois qu'il
faut tirer la leçon de cette crise parce
que les médecins libéraux en particulier
ils ont très chèrement payé cette dérive
dans l'organisation de l'état et 7
failli dans la nation de l'état
je reviendrai pas sur les masques
heureusement que les collectivités
locales que les élus locaux nous ont
aidés nous aurons à porter des masques
dans nos cabinets dans les centres covit
que nous avions monté parce que nous
avons eu un retard énorme à être doté en
masque pour prendre cet exemple ça a été
pareil pour les tests sur la vaccination
une organisation très hospital au centre
et je me bats depuis bien longtemps pour
que les médecins de ville puisse accéder
à tous les vaccins en particulier les
arn messager bref tout ça est très
structurée autour des offreurs de soins
et 6 ha dont souffre notre système de
santé et dans les préconisations que je
ferai la première c'est une
préconisation sur la gouvernance et
l'organisation
je crois qu'il faut revoir la
gouvernance du système de santé et il
faut effectivement s'appuyer sur la
réponse aux besoins
il faut que l'état devienne un état
stratège mais il faut établir la réponse
aux besoins à partir des réalités
territoriales et s'appuyer sur les
professionnels de ville
la médecine de ville qui doit être au
premier plan de cet organisme
sion de la réponse aux besoins de la
population en lien avec les élus locaux
avec les collectivités locales
et il faut élaborer cette réponse aux
besoins de la population en se reposant
sur cette réalité du quotidien et pas à
partir de l'avenue de ségur siège du
ministère de la santé une nouvelle
organisation basée sur le premier niveau
de réponse aux besoins de la population
et une gouvernance qui fait de l'état
le stratège mais qui fait des acteurs
professionnels et territoriaux ceux qui
doivent organiser la réponse deuxièmre
conisation bien sûr c'est comment
répondre mieux aux besoins de la
population en termes d'accès aux soins
et c'est la première tic dont tu parles
et jean-pierre celle des déserts
médicaux comment on en est arrivé là
les causes sont multiples il n'y a pas
de remède unique est le remède qui
consisterait à faire mettre fin la
liberté d'installation est donnée aux
jeunes praticiens une obligation d'aller
exercer dans tel ou tel endroit pendant
x années c'est on le voit dans les pays
où ça a été tenté c'est un remède qui
toujours abouti à un échec
alors il faut accompagner cette mutation
de l'exercice médical
oui nous n'aurons pas demain un médecin
au pied de chaque clocher
c'est un constat parce que en exerce la
médecine différemment parce
qu'aujourd'hui nous manquons de médecins
on va en avoir un peu plus dans les 5 à
10 années à venir
mais de toute façon quoi qu'il en soit
l'exercice sera différent parce que
l'exercice se fait en équipe en équipe
de plusieurs médecins de plusieurs
médecins de plusieurs spécialités avec
d'autres professionnels de santé avec
des infirmières des kinés des
orthophonistes et caetera et caetera et
la plupart du temps dans des structures
qui sont regroupés qui sont coordonnés
alors moi je suis contre le modèle
unique je suis contre les maisons de
santé pluriprofessionnelle à tous crins
contre l'essai pts les communautés
professionnelles territorial de santé à
tous crins je crois qu'il faut laisser
l'initiative vous pouvez
lionel il ya des outils qui sont
intéressants je citais les maisons de
santé professeur pluri professionnelle
les fameuses et pts mais il y en a
d'autres et il faut laisser cette
initiative à l'eau provient de santé qui
sont des libéraux en ville
ivo s'organiser pour répondre aux
besoins on l'a fait pendant la crise du
coc vide et on l'a très bien fait
d'ailleurs et on s'est affranchi de
toutes ces règles toute cette
bureaucratie c'est aussi etc
et je crois que c'est vraiment ce qu'il
faut faire répondre aux veaux à la
demande dans les déserts médicaux
c'est donc accompagné cette évolution de
l'exercice médical à l'hiver
regroupement des professionnels et aller
vers des exercices multisites et c'est
comme ça qu'on rapprochera l'offre de
soins des besoins de la population vous
n'aurez pas un médecin dans chaque
village de 800 âmes
c'est plus possible par contre vous
pouvez très bien avoir un médecin qui
vient de trois fois par semaine faire
une consultation avancer c'est la même
chose pour la médecine spécialisée et
j'ai lu votre document avec beaucoup
d'intérêt il ya des éléments que je
trouve très bien fait et je salue cette
initiative
je regrette que pas un mot sur les
métiers spécialisés libéral en france
c'est typique de la façon dont on
raisonne aujourd'hui dans le pays
en médecine de ville on ne voit que la
médecine générale et les français le
savent
attention ils vont nous reprocher de ne
pas avoir su sauver la médecine
spécialisée de proximité accéder à un
psychiatre en ville c'est très difficile
trouver un pédiatre aujourd'hui c'est
difficile demain y en aura plus accéder
à un endocrinologue un rhumatologue et
cetera
c'est très difficile aujourd'hui parce
qu'il y en a de moins en moins il faut
soutenir cette offre de soins de qualité
spécialisés et ne pas se centrer
uniquement sur les déserts médicaux
pour ça il faut ouvrir la formation il
faut faire des écoles des facultés de
médecine de véritables écoles
professionnelles développé des stages en
ville en ruralité en clinique privée
dans des cabinets de médecine générale
ou dans les cabinets des autres
spécialités
parce que la faculté de médecine c'est
comme ça qu'est le donnera l'ouverture
vers l'exercice en ville et que nos
jeunes générations seront séduits par ce
qu'est un médecin libéral et libéral ça
commence comme liberté et c'est ce que
je dis souvent à mes jeunes collègues
troisième préconisations il faut
améliorer les conditions d'exercice je
disais il faut accompagner le
regroupement est là il faut que l'état
investisse il a prévu un grand plan
d'investissement pour l'hôpital public
et c'est bien parce que l'hôpital en
avait besoin
il faut que l'état investisse sur la
médecine de ville parce que nous n'avons
pas aujourd'hui les moyens de nous
regrouper de construire des structures
qui permettent d'accueillir largement
des médecins de différentes spécialités
avec d'autres professionnels et pour
cela il va falloir investir sur la
médecine de ville
il va falloir investir sur la valeur de
l'acte médical 25 euros pour voir un
médecin généraliste conventionné secteur
est aujourd'hui on voit qu'au nez
complètement déconnecté de l'échelle des
services en france au nez à grosso modo
la moitié de la valeur de l'acte médical
de médecine générale en europe qui
étaient 47 euros
et aujourd'hui il est fondamental de
revaloriser tous les actes médicaux
la consultation de base mais aussi les
consultations chez les médecins
spécialistes mais aussi les actes
médicaux qui sont dans la nomenclature
des actes médicaux en chirurgie etc etc
dont je pense que vraiment il ya un
investissement très important à faire de
ce point de vue là et puis il faut
accompagner cette évolution de
l'exercice médical parce que les
médecins libéraux ce sont des
entrepreneurs
ce sont des entrepreneurs qui prennent
beaucoup d'initiatives pour répondre aux
besoins de la population et qui de plus
en plus demain exerceront à plusieurs en
groupe
et de demain ils vont évoluer vers de
véritables établissements de santé
libéraux à leurs mains en de véritables
entreprises médicales libérales
ça nécessite un investissement de l'état
pour accompagner cette nouvelle
organisation de l'exercice médical
quatrième préconisations et j'en
terminerai là c'est l'innovation
nous avons un défi à relever aujourd'hui
c'est l'arrivée du numérique en matière
de santé il va falloir accompagner cette
mutation du numérique en santé et on
peut pas rester aujourd'hui dans cette
frilosité cas l'assurance maladie sur la
télémédecine
quand vous pensez que nous avons des
outils connectés qui permettent de
surveiller les patients à domicile dans
ce qu'on appelle de la télésurveillance
ça existe depuis des années et connaît
toujours sur des articles 51 cm sur de
l'expérimentation ce n'est pas dans le
droit commun on est encore au moyen âge
quand vous pensez que la téléexpertise
aujourd'hui elle est rémunérée à 12
euros vous rendez compte en emploi un
terme qui est la téléexpertise d'un
médecin qui fait dix ans d'études en le
rémunère 12 euros quand il fait de la
télé expertise via le numérique en santé
voilà où on en est aujourd'hui et on
s'étonne se décolle pas attendez je
crois que là aussi il faut être un peu
raisonnable
la téléconsultation a été boostée par
l'épisode de koh vide
il va falloir continuer ce mouvement et
développer la télémédecine
mais ça veut dire aussi investir sur
l'innovation médecine sur la recherche
la recherche clinique sur le la
recherche pharmaceutique
sur l'ensemble de ces secteurs qui
aujourd'hui sont en déshérence et j'ai
été très séduit par tout ce qui a été
dit sur l'indépendance nationale en
matière sanitaire
on en a trop souffert il faut absolument
assurer à la france une indépendance
nationale parce qu'on ne peut pas
continuer à dépendre en particulier sur
les médicaments de pays comme l'inde ou
la chine qui sont les deux pays qui
fabriquent aujourd'hui les principes
actifs dans lequel
en 1 l'ensemble des médicaments ni très
dépendants par rapport au ca dont je
pense que là vraiment il va falloir
accompagner cette innovation accompagner
cette innovation c'est le gage de la
coordination de tous les acteurs grâce
aux outils numériques et c'est le gage
de la qualité en santé parce que j'ai
dit tout à l'heure en commençant à
propos que notre système était très
cloisonné
parce que malheureusement on manque de
systèmes d'information performants et là
aussi c'est le numérique qui va nous
permettre ça donc on a des défis très
importants à relever
nous avons des professionnels engagés on
a aujourd'hui des mesures qui doivent
être prises de façon à mieux répondre à
l'ensemble de ses besoins
merci merci beaucoup pour jour est
vraiment remercier nos trois no 3 nos
trois experts que ce soit frédéric
bizarre philippe juvin où vous docteur
jean paul ortiz hong hong et c'est de
cette manière que deux collègues
parlementaires ont travaillé sur les sur
les propositions c'est à dire que on
voit bien la défaillance et philippe et
frédéric l'ont bien mis en exergue la
défaillance sur la gouvernance c'est à
dire que l'état n'est pas là pour tout
faire d'ailleurs en règle générale mais
c'est la même chose
j'irai dans dans l'industrie dans
l'entreprise une manière générale
lorsque l'état se substitue aux
professionnels rarement il fonctionne
bien en revanche le rôle de l'état c'est
d'organiser un contexte enfin un
environnement qui soit favorable à
l'initiative à la recherche à la
décentralisation aussi de répondre au
plus proche des besoins c'est ce que
vous venez d'évoquer à l'instar monsieur
ortiz on voit bien les pertes
d'efficacité qu'ont pu être les nôtres
et d'ailleurs comment les les médecins
libéraux
les professionnels de santé aussi au
sein des hôpitaux avec les collectivités
territoriales ont su réagir
c'est à dire un moment quand ils se sont
démarqués de l'organisation de santé
telles qu'elles étaient là en disant
quand on est un élu de territoire et et
philippe ii
j'irai de de faire une mi temps dans
chaque camp ou de boxer dans les deux
catégories
on prend à bras le corps parce que
lorsqu'on est élu local
on n'est pas là pour défendre un système
mais pour répondre aux attentes de la
population et pour ça faut s'appuyer à
la fois sur les professionnels mais il
faut aussi et c'était tout l'analyse des
frédéric bizarre avoir un système de
gouvernance qui nous permette cette
réactivité cet esprit d'initiative et
donc c'est à partir de cela que l'on a
bâti nos propositions donc je crois que
c'est philippe qui démarre sont là on a
fait 3 3 blocs de propositions philippe
annie et jean pierre vont se succéder
pour présenter et commenter nos
propositions
philippe je te laisse démarré sur le
premier bloc absolument juste avant
peut-être une remarque sur
l'intervention de docteur ortiz
concernant les libéraux spécialiste pour
qui ait pas d'ambiguïté nous nous
croyons effectivement qu'un des moteurs
du choix de l'exercice médical ce sont
les rencontres
on a tous fait des métiers et provisions
parce qu'un jour on a rencontré
quelqu'un on s'est dit celui-là il est
tellement bien que je veux lui
ressembler et donc dans nos propositions
il ya l'idée que nous fixerons un
objectif très ambitieux jusque peut-être
une année ça se construit durant les
études ou on demandera aux étudiants
d'aller faire leurs études n'ont pas
leur stage non pas l'hôpital mais en
ville et donc par définition aussi chez
les spécialistes quand je dis en ville
c'est en réalité plus large c'est en
ville ou en établissements de santé
publics privés etc
donc nous nous croyons beaucoup à ça et
vous avez raison et la médecine générale
n'est pas la totalité
évidemment de la médecine de médecine
non hospitalière alors sur les
propositions
donc c'est moi qui lance le bal c'est ça
c'est sûr donc voilà nous avons à
l'écran et donc vous avez tous ses
avoirs à l'écran par numéro et vous avez
emballer les petits pourcentages c'est
que comme à chaque fois toutes nos
propositions sont soumises aux militants
et aux votes de nos militants qui ont
réagi sur nos propositions
vas-y fini donc la première proposition
c'est la proposition je crois qu'il
rejoint les propositions des différents
experts
des parlementaires c'est qu'il ya
beaucoup d' agence il ya le système est
très émietté ce qu'on demande à l'état
sait que ce sera un état stratège
stratège il faut qu'il ait une colonne
vertébrale la colonne vertébrale ça
s'appelle une agence unique
c'est ce que frédéric avait dit tout à
l'heure une agence sanitaire nationale
qui regroupe les trente deux agences
actuelles trente deux 32 et une
programmation sanitaires à cinq ans voté
par le parlement
donc ça c'est le décor général qui
redonne de la structuration au système
et ensuite à une deuxième proposition
qui est la question de la prévention
évidemment on a bien compris qu avec ce
système la crise qu'on a vécu la
prévention c'est aussi ce qui nous fait
gagner des vies c'est ce qui nous fait
gagner de l'argent c'est ce qui nous
fait gagner de l'énergie c'est ce qui
nous économise des moyens également et
il faut mettre la pression impressions
sur la prévention
un budget de prévention en augmentation
au niveau de celui de nos voisins
européens
un système de visites régulières à
différents âges de la vie et parce que
il ya également d'autres propositions
qui sont faire faire également de la
prévention avec tous les objets
connectés qui sont des mots qui peuvent
être des révolutions dans les années à
venir avec l'utilisation du big data de
l'intelligence artificielle
là on a une prévention qui va pouvoir
peut-être prendre un essor qu'elle
n'avait pas pris dans le passé justement
grâce aux nouvelles technologies
la troisième proposition c'est un peu le
pendant de la première c'est que du coup
on a un état stratège d'un côté mais on
a une mise en oeuvre de la stratégie de
santé qui peut être au plus proche du
territoire et c'est la fameuse
territorialisation de ce système et nous
souhaitons que les présidents de région
puisse prendre la présidence de l'agencé
régionale de santé évidemment un lien
avec le préfet puisque l'état est
toujours présent en france mais on voit
très bien qu'on veut donner le pouvoir
aux acteurs de terrain 7 c c'est
peut-être une des grandes leçons de la
crise c'est qu'en fait nous avons
redécouvert la vertu des circuits courts
et là où l'état n'arrivait pas acheté de
masquer les régions y arrivait quand
même incroyable
le circuit court ça fonctionne et y
compris au niveau déjà l'engrenage de
santé la quatrième proposition
c'est une vaste propositions pour
comprends bien c'est la
débureaucratisation
c'est cet ensemble de structures qui se
nourrit elle même qui prend le temps de
ceux qui auraient du temps à passer
auprès du patient et puis là aussi c'est
la vertu du circuit court à l'hôpital
par exemple
en fait ça a fonctionné pourquoi parce
que les acteurs ont pris leur
indépendance ils ont fonctionné
totalement différemment de ce qu'on leur
avait dit qu de fer et en fait on a mis
à plat les structures habituelles
j'ai souvenir que je sais plus qui a dit
qu on ouvrait des lits de réanimation en
trois jours là où habituellement
médisants obtenir une autorisation et
c'est vrai c'est ce qu'on a fait et donc
pourquoi parce que là encore et je
reviens ce que je vous disais tout à
l'heure en introduction c'est que nous
croyons nous croyons à la société et
nous croyons en un an dans les individus
ce sont eux qui ont porté la crise ce
sont eux qui peuvent porter des réformes
et des typiquement au niveau du service
hospitalier
c'est une c'est une affaire qu'il faut
faire et le docteur ortiz l'a très bien
dit aussi en médecine de ville
c'est aussi donner le pouvoir aux gens
de s'organiser comme ils le veulent il
n'y a pas un système identique de
dunkerque à ajaccio chacun a son système
et s'adapte la proposition suivante
c'est la cinquième
c'est la question de la rémunération des
personnels il ya la question des heures
supplémentaires vous savez dans les
établissements publics de santé qui ne
sont effectués qui ne sont pas récupérés
il ya un vrai sujet là dessus et le le
ségur de la santé a été un début de
commencement de réponse
mais quand on regarde les rémunérations
obtenu à l'issue du ségur
on arrive tout juste à la moyenne de
l'union européenne
donc on est encore loin et il ya un
sujet là dessus enfin sixième point
ça c'est ma proposition un peu perso
même si c'est pas moi qui ai rédigé mais
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec tout
ce qu'il ya dessus c'est la
désengorgement des urgences
pourquoi parce que les urgences d'une
certaine manière c'est aussi
l'expression de l'hospital aux
centristes que le docteur ortiz et
expliquer à ces que les urgences les
gens y vont aussi par défaut et ils vont
par défaut à la fois parce que parfois
ils n'ont pas les moyens de médecine de
ville pour les recevoir
et aussi parce qu'on les a habitués on
est un système qui les habitue donc nous
souhaitons c'est généraliser le
dispositif ça si vous savez une sorte de
filtre en fait à l'entrée des urgences à
travers un premier filtre téléphonique
c'est le danemark qui le fait depuis des
années il n'y a pas de raison de qu'on
soit plus bêtes que les autres on va y
arriver
et puis guider les gens au téléphone
sont là par leurs besoins de santé c'est
à dire que au lieu de téléphonie en
disant enfin ils ont téléphoné au lieu
de dire aller aux urgences de l'hôpital
cochin et bien on leur dira mais il ya
le docteur ortiz qu'elle son cabinet qui
est tout à fait disponible demain à 9
heures il peut vous recevoir
là ça s'organise ça s'appelle la passe
l'hospitalisation direct c'est
fondamental on voit aujourd'hui il ya un
grand mouvement ça fait 25 ans que peu à
peu ça se passe comme ça quand un
médecin de ville veut faire hospitaliser
impatient il doit passer par les
urgences
c'est dingue alors que parfois le
patient est connue d'un service de
l'hôpital
donc nous voulons mettre fin à ça et
avoir des circuits courts qui permettent
au patient de court circuiter les
urgences et puis évidemment généraliser
la pratique en hôpital pour les médecins
libéraux volontaires l'idée aussi c'est
de retisser un système de santé qui soit
pas cloisonnés et quoi de mieux pour
décloisonner assystem que les acteurs se
partagent entre les différents exercices
voilà christian les premières
propositions
merci merci philippe on pense tout de
suite au deuxième bloc pour avoir le
temps du débat tout à l'heure avec nos
internautes là c'est
jean pierre qui va nous présenter les
propositions alors sous l'angle à la
fois le jeu le docteur ortiz a évoqué
tout à l'heure la performance et
l'efficacité et comment on en est
réactif dans les meilleures conditions
merci christian oui la proposition
numéro 7 que vous allez voir apparaître
ces on n'a pas la solution
personne ne la solution tout à l'heure
on l'a évoqué avec jean paul ortiz c'est
la lutte contre les déserts médicaux il
y a des propositions c'est effectivement
et les collectivités locales sont prêtes
à jouer ce jeu de réussite c'est de
faciliter l'installation des nouveaux
médecins en particulier sur le plan
fiscal en particulier éventuellement en
aidant dans les logements en aidant dans
la solution de transport entre leur
situation et les préfectures ou les
grandes villes
c'est à dire d'avoir des solutions de
transport de logement est évidemment de
fiscalité éventuelles bien entendu on
avait parlé des stages des étudiants en
médecine qui doivent être au minimum de
6 mois sinon un nom ce sera encore mieux
et que ce soit dans les cabinets de
médecine libérale ou de médecine
spécialisée dans les établissements
privés également et concret ce qu'on a
appelé un peu des centres ambulatoires
universitaire c'est à dire que dans ces
centres où ils vous avez plusieurs
médecins qui se sont organisés depuis
longtemps qu'ils puissent recevoir des
étudiants en médecine pour les
remplacements pour des stages pendant
quelques mois et bien entendu on a voulu
on a vu que la téléconsultation a
explosé lors de la crise du corps vide
la sécurité sociale que j'ai pu
interroger dernièrement souhaite ne pas
du tout réduire la téléconsultation dans
les années à venir
je l' ai personnellement mme organisé
depuis trois ou quatre ans dans les
territoires ruraux
c'est à dire qu'avec le soutien des
mairies des municipalités qui met à
disposition à cabinet médical et des
infirmières libérales
sont à disposition dans ses cabinets
médicaux pour être en lien de
téléconsultation par le numérique avec
des médecins à distance les infirmières
libérales ça leur donne à un plus il à l
ou obtenues elles ont obtenu un acte de
téléconsultation qui est bien supérieur
à l'acte classique de leur métier qui
est à 12 euros la consultation
donc elles sont elles sont tout à fait
elle souhaite vraiment participer à ces
téléconsultations médicales dans les
territoires ruraux
ça permet de désengorger les urgences de
l'hôpital à proximité
dès l'instant où un patient ou un
citoyen un problème il peut aller
directement dans ces téléconsultations
comme vous n'avez pas de médecin
problème c'est quand il n'y a pas de
médecin donc c'est la lutte contre les
déserts médicaux il faut trouver toutes
les solutions que l'on puisse avoir et
il y en aura d'autres nouvelles
là-bas la numéro 8 la proposition numéro
8 c'est dans le cadre de la formation
il faut que la formation des médecins
évolué il ne faut plus que ces jeunes
médecins restent en permanence dans les
facultés et restent scotchées dans les
facultés ou dans les chu ou dans les
grands hôpitaux
il faut qu'ils puissent aller à
l'extérieur on veut également qu'il y
ait beaucoup plus de médecins
donc on a eu le numerus clausus qui a
été libéré mais c'était une c'est un une
fumée parce qu'on n'a augmenté que de
10% le nombre de numerus clausus je
pense qu'il faudra aller vraiment sûr
augmenter jusqu'à 50 % peut-être le
numerus clausus de passer de 10000 à
15000 ou seize mille par an mais à la
condition que les facultés soit en
disposition de pouvoir augmenter leurs
moyens d'accueil pour ces étudiants il
faudra donc avoir un véritable programme
de formation qui soit totalement
améliorées pour les années à venir
la proposition numéro 9 on a évoqué tout
à l'heure
jean paul lortie s'est vraiment de
valoriser les métiers de la santé
que ce soit les médecins que ce soit les
infirmières l'acte de 25 euros est
vraiment obsolète depuis x années
je crois que ça fait déjà cinq ans que
ça n'a pas bougé d'un centime
il faut qu effectivement on puisse
passer aux standards européens qui est
sonde autour de 40 à 45 euros
comme cela a été rappelé et les
infirmières libérales dont on a un grand
besoin
elles sont nombreuses c'était sont des
professionnels de proximité envers les
citoyens
quand vous pensez qu'un acte d'infirmer
est évalué à 4 euros à 7 euros pour
avoir à une une injection d'anti
coagulant domicile
c'est véritablement là encore est très
très loin du compte
il faut absolument qu'on augmente tout à
fait ces honoraires médecins infirmières
bien entendu s'engagera des dépenses
mais là ce seront des sujets qui seront
comme l'a rappelé tout à l'heure
frédéric bizarre il faut pas s'arrêter
simplement à ce qu'on appelle la dépense
strictes il faut s'engager dans la santé
a d'un coup il faut là il faut aussi
engager la et la proposition numéro 10
c'est prendre en charge ça a été dit
tout à l'heure
également je crois par jean paul lortie
c'est la santé mentale ya pas de ya plus
ou très peu de psychiatres en milieu
rural en milieu de villes comme dans les
milieux hospitaliers
il faut donc développer les infirmières
de diplôme d'état qui soit dans le
domaine de la psychiatrie que les
patients soit puce est suivi en ville
par des infirmières en relation avec les
services de médecine générale
les services de médecine spécialiste et
les services hospitaliers des
infirmières dans le milieu de ville sont
capables de prendre en charge des
patients qui sont atteints d'un problème
de santé mentale
voilà quels sont nos
10 propos nos j'en suis à la 18e à la
11e proposition qui était oui c'est donc
voilà j'ai terminé non non tu as dû en
oublier
j'en ai oublié je sais plus lequel non
non je suis là je suis bon merci merci
merci jean pierre donc on va passer à
annie sur le dernier bloc de proposition
ce qui était évoqué je crois pas par
nous trois intervenants sur à la fois la
souveraineté mais aussi la non
dépendance
sait on a découvert effectivement une
france totalement dépendante pour toutes
les raisons qui ont pu être évoquées pas
suffisamment sur l'innovation une
gouvernance qui bloque le système etc
vaziani oui oui merci cher président
c'est important de renforcer la
souveraineté de la france en matière de
la santé c'est certain et pas seulement
pour créer de nouveaux vaccins mais pour
la totalité de la production des
produits de santé et le développement de
l'innovation thérapeutique alors l'enjeu
de la souveraineté de santé et est
double pour nous parce que elle existe
ça existe au niveau national et au
niveau européen au niveau national
odeurs devenir un territoire fortement
attractif pour l'innovation
thérapeutique c'est un enjeu industriel
est aussi un enjeu d'accès aux soins
pour les patients
il faut attirer les investissements
faire développer les projets de
recherche partenariale entre le public
et le privé
c est ça doit être une priorité ça peut
passer et on va le voir par des
mécanismes incitatifs notamment sur le
plan administratif on va voir comment on
peut éviter que les laboratoires
pharmaceutiques se heurte à des
longueurs d'autorisation et aussi sur le
plan fiscal
d'autre part les les industries les
industries pharmaceutiques ne peuvent
pas être diabolisés comme c'est souvent
le cas et on l'entend beaucoup mais ils
doivent être vus comme des partenaires
intéressés financièrement c'est normal
mais qu'on va pouvoir utiliser comme
levier pour récupérer notre souveraineté
sanitaires et surtout notre place de
leader dans l'innovation santé au niveau
européen on a constaté un manque de
coordination
tant dans la production que dans la
protection des populations face aux
épidémies et il est essentiel que nous
puissions tendre vers une europe de la
santé en termes d'autonomie industriels
ça doit passer par la promotion d'un
encouragement à la relocalisation de la
production de médicaments mais une
europe de la santé ça doit aussi pouvoir
assurer la coordination de l'action
publique en matière de prévention et de
gestion
des crises épidémique et biologiques
donc je vais vous présenter les
propositions qui vont essayer excès
je vais vous présenter les propositions
qui vont nous permettre de renforcer
notre souveraineté
d'abord la proposition 13 12 as a changé
bon c'est créer un fonds souverain
français investis sements visant à
renforcer la souveraineté de notre pays
dans le domaine de la santé
c'est cette proposition c'était
d'assurer un investissement d'état sans
avoir à créer encore et toujours de la
dette pur c'est un instrument pertinent
pour enclencher une dynamique
d'investissements publics efficaces
la question suivante la proposition
suivante qui est la presse
c'est
mettre en place voilà mettre en place
une conférence innovation santé c'est
réunir une fois par an les responsables
politiques et administratifs patients
professionnels laboratoires
pharmaceutiques en est une conférence
innovation santé pour définir et
coordonner la politique d'innovation
santé et dégage et bien sûr les
priorités d'investissement en santé
publique
recenser les innovations à venir alors
moi j'ai un petit décalage dans
l'édition mais ça fait rien alors la
question suivante la question 14
la proposition 14 c'est inscrire l'enjeu
de la reconquête de notre souveraineté
sanitaire de la france en tant
qu'objectif majeur de la politique
nationale de recherche et créer un
programme recherche innovation et
transfert de technologie dans le domaine
de la santé personnalisé au sein du
projet de loi de finances c'est pour
donner un cadre aux acteurs publics et
privés de la recherche médicale pour
engager les investissements stratégiques
dans les futures conquêtes médicale
c'est une programmation de finances
publiques garantir en outre la viabilité
de l'émergence d'une filière des
médicaments très innovant et les
filières d'excellence dans les
biotechnologies la proposition 15 s'est
relocalisé les propositions oui
relocaliser en france l'a produit la
production des médicaments d'intérêt
stratégique
en définissant une liste de médicaments
d'intérêt stratégique pour lesquels les
obligations les obligations de stockage
serait renforcée au niveau français et
au niveau européen en réalisant une
cartographie des sites français de
production en partenariat avec
l'industrie pharmaceutique et la haine
et s'aiment et ensuite en mettant en
place des annexions fiscale 6
blé au bénéfice d'entreprises
s'engageant sur des investissements pour
implanter en france des sites de
production de médicaments ou de
principes actifs stratégiques
la proposition 16 s'est attirée la
production des médicaments de thérapie
innovants en france en créant une
mission de veille et de prospective sur
le développement des produits de
thérapie devant alors ça c'est une
mission qui devrait être confiée au
comité économique des produits de santé
parce qu'elle vise à anticiper l'arrivée
sur le marché des nouvelles molécules
les justes pour aller dans le sens de ce
que disait frédéric bizarre je crois le
temps procédure des mythes d'admission
au remboursement qui devrait durer
normalement 180 jours d'après les
données de la fédération européenne et
parfois de plus de 500 jours en france
donc si on essaye de 2,2 d'anticiper
l'arrivée sur le marché de nouvelles
molécules
ça permet de réduire d'autant le temps
de deux de la procédure d'admission au
remboursement donc le temps d'arriver
sur le marché des médicaments
la même chose là alors oui c'était la
même chose ici on avait dit aussi que on
pouvait aussi pour réduire les délais de
disponibilité
c'était comme la question c'est la
question précédente
établir un mécanisme dérogatoire de
commercialisation c'est le même principe
c'est pour réduire le temps d'accès du
médicament pour les patients et pour les
entreprises on pensait bien que des
entreprises et qui ont l'âme la
possibilité de commercialiser leurs
leurs médicaments dans toute l'europe
dans les pays voisins ils peuvent le
faire au bout de 180 jours ils vont pas
attendre les 500 jours français et c'est
aussi c'est dommage pour tous nos
patients et il faut réduire ses délais
absolument donc la proposition 18
il faudrait à oui on avait nommé la
proposition 17,6 des crédits la boue de
recherche et l'étendre à la phase de
développement
le nom même notamment pour les
industries pharmaceutiques qui pourrait
de cette façon
développer plus rapidement et plus
facilement la production du médicament
la 18 construire une filière e-santé
puissante et structurée par la
généralisation du dossier médical
partagé l'uniformisation des systèmes
d'information des hôpitaux et le
développement de la télémédecine et
dates et les consultations médicales
ça se voit là ça se comprend
de lui-même c'est le second problème
cette proposition la proposition 19
tirer les leçons de la crise alors se
doter des moyens de surveillance et
d'analysé épidémiologique moderne les
eaux usées le séquençage tirait des
plans d'urgence pour tirer des plans
d'urgence et des réserves stratégiques
les masques les tests les médicaments
les lits et agir au niveau européen en
constituant une réserve sanitaire
européenne et les stocks de médicaments
et d'équipements stratégique en
investissement en investissant dans une
véritable filière industrielle
européenne de la santé en créant et
l'autorité européenne pour coordonner
les réponses des états membres contre
les futures crises sanitaires
merci annie je crois que jean pierre
voulait juste ajouter un mot sur cette
proposition je voudrais juste rajouter
un mot parce que pense qu'on a fait
peut-être un oubli dans la tirer les
leçons de la crise pensent que philippe
juvin ira certainement dans mon sens
je pense qu'on pourrait rajouter dans
les plans d'urgence et les réserves
stratégiques je voudrais qu'on rende à
l'eprus son rôle stratégique
l'eprus a été créé et une dizaine
d'années et c'était cet établissement
public était chargé de stocker le
milliard et demi de masquer les 6000
respirateur les blues les les
les médicaments anti viraux les
médicaments antibiotiques et le les
dernières années ont vu la
déconstruction qui je peux dire de
l'eprus donc il faudra la commission d'
enquête sur la leçon de la crise que
nous avons fait il ya quelques mois a
donc noté dans ses conclusion qu'il
fallait rendre vie à l'eprus donc ce
serait l'occasion de d'en parler là dans
ce texte
merci jean pierre merci à tous les tous
les deux peut-être on va voir
comme à chaque convention les les
questions nos internautes et puis nos
différents intervenants se partageant
pour pour répondre j'aurais peut-être
que que d'un mot
on est une réaction de jean paul ortiz
et puis de frédéric bizarre sur sur ces
propositions puis ensuite on passe aux
questions des internautes
jean-paul je vous laisse commencer oui
merci merci de me faire réagir un show
dont je crois que les propositions qui
sont faites bien sûr il ya des des
éléments qui mériterait d'être peu plus
enrichi mais c'est le propre des débats
et on voit bien que c'est le propre de
notre démocratie justement que tout le
monde soit pas d'accord et qu'on puisse
enrichir les propositions mais
globalement à la médecine libérale se
retrouve assez largement dans ses
propositions qui alors je parlais tout à
l'heure de l'indépendance nationale au
niveau sanitaire je crois que c'est
quelque chose qui est très important
d'innovations santé le numérique rendre
des acteurs responsables sur le terrain
je crois que tout ça sont des grandes
idées qui doivent vraiment faire corps
de dans la réforme majeure qui doit voir
dans le système de santé tout à l'heure
patrick jullien le disait pendant la
crise du coc vide on a bousculé les
règles habituelles les règlements les
circulaires des trucs des machins et on
a fonctionné dans ce que nous entre non
disait on fonctionne en mode dégradé
qu'est-ce qu'on était bien en fonctionne
en mode dégradé c'est à dire en en
décision direct il fallait aller vite
c'était l'urgence
et puis et puis l'administration avec un
grand a
que ce soit les rs délégation
départementale dans les hôpitaux etc
ils sont ils se sont mis un peu de côté
forte intelligemment et les
professionnels ont pris le pouvoir
et bien je peux vous dire ça marche est
très très bien je crois que c'est ça
qu'il faut qu'on fasse tout à fait moi
je partage largement j'étais 17 ans
maire de ma ville et président de mon
conseil d'administration de l'hôpital
ayez de perception que l'on a lorsque
l'on met des les élus territoriaux là
bien évidemment ça ne change rien sur le
régalien
il y a
une partie régalienne de la médecine
ayez un rôle déterminant de l'état mais
au-delà de ça moi je vois la capacité qu
un maire est capable d'avoir avec ses
équipes avec les médecins libéraux par
les médecins de ville avec ceux de
l'hôpital avec les cliniques parce que
les lui se fait booster comme les
professionnels de santé sont imaginatifs
à partir du moment où on est plus en
forme et on laisse de l'espace à
l'innovation on voit que finalement on
arrive à réagir et c'est ça aujourd'hui
toute l'idée de la gouvernance mois que
me séduit beaucoup dans la proche de
frédéric bizarre c'est vraiment là qu'il
faut qu'on puisse rebâtir les choses
c'est à dire voir aussi sur les
économies on voit bien que si on a un
système qui laisse plus de place à
l'innovation plus de place à la
prévention à la réactivité philippe
l'évoqué tout à l'heure on a des
économies à faire lorsque on a des
patients qui ne sont pas traités avec
des maladies qui ne sont pas détectés et
bien il ya forcément une augmentation
d'abord en conséquence sanitaire sociale
évidente immédiate mais il y aussi un
coût économique a manqué de réactivité
et le noeud du problème est vraiment là
je devrais que frédéric réagissent sur
ces différentes propositions et puis
après on passe aux questions des
internautes
rapidement d'abord quel chemin parcouru
ces propositions c'est toujours délices
de propositions comme ça enfin si vous
les reprenez un petit peu là vous avez
une transformation majeure du système et
qui a l'air d'aller de soi on les a les
propositions vous les avez d'autres en
auront probablement qu'ils ont dans ce
sens donc moi je certaine satisfaction
en tout cas de voir que lyle
véritablement on prend le taureau par
les cornes tu peux m'exprimer ainsi 3,3
points
habile je vous invite à aller plus loin
sur deux sujets qui sont sensibles pour
l air parce que c est l'air qui a fait
la loi
et parce que il ya des lobbys qui sont
pas très loin de chez elles air
que vous n'abordez pas et la troisième
c'est comment comment comme on l'a fait
c'est très fort la loi hpst a été mal
calibré et
elle est on est responsable enfin les
autres ont suivi donc il n'y a pas une
auto flagellation à faire si vous prenez
les quatre lettres hôpital patients
santé territoires vous faites un bilan
dix ans après objectivement bon été mal
calibré la gouvernance de l'hôpital est
à revoir
c'est pas mentionnés pourraient pas
avoir une gouvernance aussi centralisé
comme ça dans les mains du seul
technocrates puisque les pôles de
pouvoir médical un rôle de consultant
consultatif principalement et on n'a pas
la gouvernance est centralisé il faut la
décentraliser il y avait des choses des
choses très bien de fait sur l'épaule
mais qui sont devenus purement
administratif
il faut arrêter cette ce monopole de l'
agence de rennes de l' école de rennes
qui ne forment que des directeurs
d'hôpitaux qui sont et qui est censé
être une bande donc dans la réforme de
la gouvernance
vous devez mettre la réforme de
l'hôpital
évidemment il faut une démocratie
sanitaire pas avoir peur du patient
citoyens au 21ème siècle ne peut pas
dire il faut renforcer le pouvoir des
patients faire de la prévention est pâle
et l'intégrer davantage dans la dans
cette gouvernance
donc il faut les bons donc voilà il faut
il faut repenser cette et je vois bien
là les timidités ce soit chose c'est pas
comme quoi on n'est pas obligé de se
devait gérer si vous et ça a été mal
calibré c'était la deuxième chose c'est
financement on pouvait pas faire une
grande réforme sans le financement
on est le seul pays du monde à avoir
deux étages d'assureurs qui qui finance
les mêmes prestations quasiment toutes
les prestations sont financés par deux
assureurs ont on est ce avec après les
états unis on est quand même le le
système qui de très très loin à les
dépenses administratives les plus élevés
ces 15 milliards si vous ajoutez 7
milliards pour l'assurance maladie est
quasiment 8 milliards pour les
complémentaires santé c'est pas jeter la
pierre avec les autres c'est quand vous
mettez quand vous allez acheter un
médicament 3 euros à la pharmacie vous
avez un euro cinquante deux payés par
l'assurance maladie et 50 centimes de
payer par la complémentaire or ça coûte
50 centimes de frais administratifs à la
complémentaire de rembourser des 50
centimes
enfin là aussi qu'est ce qu'on fait on
continue ou on change bon ce système est
un système de rente pour les assureurs
il faut le mettre au service des
dépressions ça veut pas dire et moi une
fois qu'on a dit ça je vais me prendre
des
déjà des pierres parce que voilà il ya
un lobby mais est ce qu'on a le courage
d'être passé au delà du lobby la
question c'est pas d'éliminer les
assureurs privés
c'est de les intégrer de façon beaucoup
plus efficace comme assureur
supplémentaires il ya tellement de
choses à faire dans l'innovation l'a dit
et notamment dans la prévention un cas
les assureurs peuvent avoir un rôle dans
l'est dans les partenariats avec les
collectivités territoriales
nos mutuelles parce que c'est elle qui
sont les plus concernés 85% du chiffre
des mythes des chiffres d'affaires des
mutuelles sont dans la santé donc mais
il ya tellement de choses à faire dans
l'économie sociale et solidaire à partir
du moment où on a une approche de santé
publique que évidemment il ya il ya un
transfert d'activité qu'il faut faire
l'idée ce n'est pas de nuire à tout ça
c'est de repenser troisième chose et
philippe juvin à côté moi me dit très
justement unis mais on est là on les a
finalement les propositions oui on va
les avoir
on va avoir le programme vous allez la
voir d'autres vont l'avoir
mais la différence elle se fera sur
l'incarnation du programme parce que ça
peut pas être une liste à la prévert de
propositions bien sûr qu'il la faut
comme vous l'avez là et après vous
l'incarnez il faut raconter une histoire
aux gens et il faut trouver un consensus
parce qu'il n'y aura pas de réforme de
gauche ou de droite il y aura une
réforme systémique qui va emmener
suffisamment avoir un point de consensus
suffisant et emmené suffisamment de
citoyens pour avoir un nouveau modèle de
santé pour les 50 prochaines années
et donc je crois que voilà il ya en tout
cas et 3 je suggère merci merci philippe
tu veux rajouter quelque chose je suis
d'accord avec les deux intervenants il
ya il ya beaucoup de choses dans le
programme par exemple vous parlez de la
loi hpst
c'est vrai qu'elle n'est pas cité mais
dans une des propositions nous disons
très clairement que nous voulons
redonner de l'autonomie aux acteurs par
exemple au chef de service
ça c'est pas du tout dans la loi hpst
puisque la loi hpst supprimait quasiment
les services donc on s'attaque vraiment
aux dysfonctionnements tout simplement
parce qu on fait le bilan l'idée c'est
pas d'être pour ou contre une loi la loi
est une construction humaine est là
elle a des qualités là étaient faux dix
ans plus tard en plus la société a
évolué on a une population plus âgée
plus nombreuses plus malade plus
d'affection de longue durée des désirs
de la population qui ont changé donc
dont nous sommes tout à fait ouverts à
tirer les leçons de ce que nous avons
fait dans le passé en bien ou en mal
et en bien et en mal de ce qu'on fait
aussi nos adversaires politiques entre
nous puisque je vous rappelle qu'il ya
dix ans que je peux au pouvoir allez on
va passer aux questions internautes les
déserts médicaux progressent et
constitue un grave sujet d'inquiétude
dans les territoires au point de devenir
un problème de santé publique
les maisons médicales mises en place à
grands frais ne sont pas la réponse et
nos concitoyens ne les plébiscites pas
que proposez-vous pour redonner l'envié
de s'installer à nos confrères et plus
généralement pour la santé c'était une
question adressée d'abord à monsieur
d'or oui merci
je pense que je vais demander j'ai
demandé à jean paul ortiz de répondre
puisque je lui avais posé la question
tout à l'heure et puis on pourra la
compléter éventuellement oui merci merci
jean pierre c'est une question difficile
et si c'est vraiment le problème de fond
notre système de santé
ghana d'autres mais c'est vraiment un
problème qui fortement ressentie par la
population française parce que
malheureusement aujourd'hui il y à des
millions de français qui ont du mal à
trouver un médecin traitant qui ont des
rendez vous extrêmement long pour
accéder à un médecin spécialiste et on a
des zones en particulier en ruralité
mais pas que n'oublions pas dans les
quartiers difficiles dans les hyper
centre ville où on a l'équivalent de
déserts médicaux on dit souvent
paris va devenir un désert médical en
matière de médecine générale
il n'y a pas une solution miracle il n'y
a pas une mesure il ya un panel de
mesures qui doivent accompagner cette
évolution de l'exercice médical
la formation on en a parlé donner le
goût aux jeunes de s'installer mais
c'est aussi faire découvrir aux jeunes
ce qu'est un cabinet médical ce qu'est
la gestion et l'organisation du système
de santé une entreprise médicale
libérale c'est pas évident on ne forme
pas du tout à ça la à la faculté donc
après quand les jeunes rentrent dans les
cabinets médicaux libéraux et qu'ils
voient ce dont on est obligés de
s'occuper tous les jours ils sont
effrayés
parce qu'ils n'ont pas du tout été formé
à ça et puis il faut accompagner le
nouvel exercice médical qui regroupait
l'exercice multisites l'exercice mixte
un peu à l'hôpital un peu en libéral et
penser qu'aujourd'hui il faut aussi
s'occuper de l'environnement du médecin
d'abord parce que le médecin dans 70 %
des cas c'est une femme médecin
mais même lorsque c'est un jeune médecin
homme il veut allier sa vie
professionnelle et sa vie personnelle
ça veut dire qu'il faut penser aux
transports aux écoles éventuellement à
l'accompagnement du conjoint pour
trouver une solution
et pour pour son emploi etc etc c'est
toutes ces mesures là au delà des
mesures fiscales des incitations 2
de d'accompagnement financier que l'on
peut faire qui doivent permettre aux
jeunes générations de venir exercer en
réalité dans les déserts médicaux dans
les quartiers difficiles et dans les
quartiers difficiles n'oublions pas
quelque chose qui est très prégnant pour
le médecin aujourd'hui et sas moi ça me
révolte c'est la sécurité dans les
cabinets médicaux
j'ai certains de mes confrères qui des
plaques qui dévissent leur plaque
parce qu'ils sont agressés parce que
leur cabinet médical et tagué parce
qu'ils sont vandalisés parce qu'ils sont
cambriolés et ça c'est plus possible de
médecins il passe son temps à être dans
l' écoute dans l'empathie à soulager les
malades et je crois que vraiment il doit
avoir un extraordinaire respect de la
part de la population pour son
engagement professionnel jean paul pour
conclure pour conclure cette prise de
deux questions la question je dois te la
pause et contraintes ou non contrainte à
l'installation
c'est une grande question qui intéresse
toute la population la réponse elle est
simple tous les pays qui ont mis en
place un système de contraintes anti
chou et pourquoi parce que les jeunes
médecins ne s'installe pas les jeunes
médecins font autre chose
il remplace un peu ils partent dans
d'autres dans d'autres circuits au
niveau de la médecine pharmaceutique qui
est plus rémunératrices et cetera
il s'installe pas donc on n'y arrivera
pas par la contrainte est au contraire
ça va détourner les jeunes générations
de nos métiers
et puis la contrainte on peut la mettre
en place
lorsqu'on a un manque criant de médecins
dans certains endroits et un excédent
d'autres c'est pas le cas actuellement
c'était pas du tout la même situation
pour les infirmières ou la démographie
médicale en infirmières et aides un
rapport de 1 à 10 suivant les
départements considéré en matière
médicale renard une différence de
démographie par département qui d'un
rapport de
à 1,7 et à l'intérieur d'un même
département on voit bien qu'il ya de
grandes inégalités de répartition de
l'implantation des médecins libéraux
non je crois qu'il faut vraiment les
aider les accompagner leur faire
découvrir notre métier qu'était un
métier absolument passionnant et puis
eux leur donner le goût de ce que je
disais tout à l'heure
libéra ses libertés on est notre propre
entrepreneurs on est notre propre patron
et ça aujourd'hui c'est une valeur
extraordinaire
hors frais des riches on voulait réagir
d'un mot papa en a beaucoup d'autres
questions vraiment désertification
médicale moi ça me fait toujours sourire
parce que c'est une
c'est une désertification général ça a
commencé à l'hôpital désertification
médicale 30% des postes de péage
praticiens hospitaliers ne sont pas
occupés vous avez une désertification de
plus en plus dans le personnel
paramédical maintenant en effet dans un
certain nombre de territoires qui sont
aussi des déserts de service public
c'est pour un certain nombre un médecin
quand il vient homme ou femme besoin il
vient avec une famille il a aussi besoin
de vivre on voit que c'est pas le cas
dans toutes les régions
c'est le cas dans les ehpad on voit que
les états deviennent des déserts et ça
c'est une interprétation personnelle je
crains que les prochains mois soit assez
dramatique de ce point de vue là parce
que la crise qu vide a tellement tiré
sur les capacités des soignants que
beaucoup risquent de jeter l'épongé
donc ce que l'on voit là je crains que
dans six mois et ce qui fera que ce dont
on discute ce soir ça nous paraît déjà
très important mais je pense que dans
six mois
ça va être encore plus important et ça
c'est ma prévision dernier point c'est
le triptyque gouvernance financement
organisation qui sur lequel il faut
jouer pour recréer de l'attractivité
parce que c'est une question
d'attractivité
c'est comme l'industrie pharmaceutique
il faut voir comment je peux attirer de
nouveau les ressources les talents sur
mon territoire
c'est exactement la même chose la
question de désertification comment je
re créer de l'attractivité donner
beaucoup plus de pouvoir à ceux qui font
la santé comme ça a été dit qu'ils
soient médecins ou qu'ils soient
paramédical vous allez voir ça va tout
changer
arrêtons de normes et a priori et wallon
a posteriori mais ça l'administration on
est incapable elle fonctionne pas comme
ça donc il faut pas lui donner ce
pouvoir d'organiser
priori donc là on est dans la
gouvernance le financement ça a été dit
enfin on est sur un financement qui jean
paul ortiz a très bien dit 12 euros sur
la téléexpertise vont dire regardez
comme c'est magnifique on lance la
téléexpertise voilà ce qui a été dit
aussi par jean paul ortiz qui est très
important c'est les sons laissons faire
les sons n'a pas affaire à des gens qui
comme ça sont vos partir à l'aventuré
dans des organisations sur rien c'est en
plus quand vous êtes libéral c'est que
vous avez plutôt intérêt à être
performant parce que si l'on vous avait
pas de patients tel bond pourrait
continuer comme ça laissons si les gens
faire du mal ou faire du salariat à
quand en général un homme politique
c'est pas quoi dire il va dire je vais
salariés 300 médecins dont même
département où je vais créer des maisons
de santé pluriprofessionnelle la réponse
bon donc question suivante jean marc et
de châtillon sur cher face aux nombreux
variant de lakovic 19 sans parler de la
vaccination en cours
quels sont les moyens déployés pour
découvrir ces variants et les contrer
dans notre pays je pense c'est une
question qui sont laissés à vous filmer
un premier tri alors quand on vous fait
le prélèvement au fond d'une et qui est
très désagréable on vous répond positif
ou négatif
vous avez vous n'avez pas mais on ne
vous dit pas quel est le type de
variants est-ce que cet invariant indien
est ce que ça variant brésilien breton
et ses cendres sais pas il faut faire un
examen qu'on appelle le séquençage
le séquençage cette demande un
savoir-faire une technique du matériel
des personnels en france on ne fait
quasiment pas le séquençage on est
aveugle en fait quand on vous dit les
variants il y en a 6 % en réalité c'est
sur une toute petite partie de dés
variant de qui circulent qu'on le mesure
c'est un peu comme si on faisait un
sondage sur un tout petit échantillon
il ya pour ceux ci voulaient vérifier il
ya un site qui s'appelle le gie side j'
y ait said et qui est l'endroit où ont
tous les états post toutes les
identifications deux variantes donc on
voit quel est le pourcentage des
prélèvements qui sont séquencé en france
c'est de l'ordre de 0,5 0,6 pour cent de
tous les prélèvements naso qui sont
séquencé en grande bretagne on est aux
alentours de 25% et donc les anglais
savent précisément quels sont les
variants kirk
nous on sait pas alors on va vous dire
qu'on fait du criblage c'est une autre
technique mais beaucoup moins précises
par exemple elle ne permet pas de
différencier entre invariants sud
africain et invariants brésilien est
donc toutes les cartes graphiques on
vous donne en france sont fausses
comment on fait pas une question d'abord
de savoir faire de culture d'équipement
nous sommes microscopique mans organisé
et puis il n'y a pas de partie il ya
très peu de collaboration public privé
il ya des tas de gens du privé qui
pourrait le faire et d'ailleurs qui
attendent que de le faire mais ça c'est
aussi un marché
eh bien on leur demande pas de faire
donc là aussi il faut tirer des leçons
mais ça fait maintenant un an qu'on est
somnambule voilà on avance comme ça on
sait pas très bien ce qui se passe et
c'est vraiment très inquiétant parce que
par exemple les britanniques savent très
bien qu actuellement il ya une remontée
du nombre de cas pas des
hospitalisations et du nombre de cas à
cause d'un variant qui veut variant
indien nous on prétend qu'il est sur le
territoire mais en réalité on sait pas
trop parce qu'on ne mesure pas vrai en
france mesure pas les choses
vous savez c'est comme quand le médecin
vous prend pas la température et puis je
vous dis ben vous n'êtes pas de fièvre
mais quand vous prend pas la température
n'a pas pu ajouter quelque chose madame
robert de montauban pourquoi le système
hospitalier français est-il devenu aussi
administratifs
c'était une question pour vous également
pardon pas écouté d'abord jeu il ya
sûrement eu d'abord il ya une
explication culturelle en france on
attend tout l'état propose que l'état va
tout régler
souvenez vous il ya un an quand ça
allait très mal qu'est ce qu'on disait à
bas l'armée va venir et on a ce on a ce
ce fantasme que il ya des pouvoirs
magiques des réserves stratégiques qui
avec l'état sait tout faire non ce n'est
pas vrai l'état ne sait pas tout faire
donc d'où ça vient c'est très culturelle
nous sommes un pays très centralisé
il faut qu'on apprenne à être agile et
l'agilité c'est la décentralisation et
c'est de pouvoir donner aux citoyens
encore une fois l'état
parfois ce n'est pas la solution parfois
c'est le problème
gg je rebondirai d'un point là dessus
j'ai présidé comme poule et comme tous
les maires mon hôpital
et effectivement sur la loi hpst quand
on est passé de président du conseil
d'administration à président du conseil
de surveillance
ça a changé largement la donne est là
quand le système ccc adapté jean-paul
nordiste le artistes le disait très bien
c'est parce qu'on a laissé faire les
professionnels comme philippe l'évoqué
aussi dire que quand on dit au chef de
service vous débrouiller pour le
recrutement
bah ils sont imaginatifs et pire
organismes notre service qu'entend on
laisse la la main là aussi au président
d'un président de conseil
d'administration pour piloter à
l'échelle de son territoire politique de
santé pour trouver les accords avec les
libéraux et c'est parce que le maire les
libéraux et les contacts tous les jours
et on imaginatif or là on est arrivé à
un système sclérosant c'est à dire que
le président du conseil de surveillance
contrairement au président du conseil
d'administration paravent d'un hôpital
président du conseil de surveillance il
distribue la parole aux uns et aux
autres il fait le tour de table et puis
après son pouvoir se limite un peu à
cela alors en fonction de sa
personnalité temps en temps il s'en
affranchit et heureusement qu'un certain
nombre s'en sont affranchis pour réagir
mais c'est de ça dont il faut vraiment
sortir aujourd'hui pour moi c'est
vraiment l'enseignement sur la
gouvernance
il est vrai sur le régalien au plus haut
niveau mais il est vrai vraiment sur le
plan local moi je crois beaucoup à cette
capacité d'organisation et et comme sur
la la question la question précédente
on voit bien il n'y a pas un système
général pour quand on parle des des
déserts médicaux et la frédéric bizarre
il disait très bien c'est un tout c'est
l'attractivité d'un territoire et
l'attractivité d'un territoire il faut
effectivement des services publics il
faut des systèmes qui soit adaptée à ce
territoire parce que lorsqu'on est dans
un centre ville avec un réseau de bus
qui fonctionne h24 dans certaines villes
ou de manière ou même sur les 2,8 dans
d'autres mais vous avez un système de
transport qui fonctionne lorsque vous
êtes sur des territoires ruraux il faut
une autre une autre adaptation c'est une
c'est une évidence lorsque vous avez sur
un territoire un hôpital avec un service
des urgences et des complémentarités con
retrouvez avec le saas qui est évoqué
philippe tout à l'heure et c'est cet
espace de liberté qu'il faut qu'il faut
vraiment retrouver pour s'en sortir donc
les deux niveaux de gouvernance sont
essentiels frédéric intéressante parce
que c'est là où je pense que la réforme
de la santé peut pas en avoir 36 dans un
quinquennat parce que nécessite la
réforme de l'état
les tout à l'heure sur le par rapport au
ministère mais cela dit c'est crozier
qui l'expliqué très bien les 80 c'est
que l'administration française est
organisée selon deux piliers c'est la
stratification des ressources humaines
et la centralisation de la prise de
décision
ça c'est depuis le début du 19e siècle
très honnêtement je ne pense pas que ça
chambre ça veut dire que l'état des
n'est pas capable dans la durée sont pas
des exceptions d'être extrêmement
réactif
l'état n'a pas de compétences médicales
l'état n'est pas capable de décider à
partir du terrain parce que ceux qui
sont sur le terrain n'ont aucun pouvoir
les rs c'est extrêmement intéressant
pour ça c'est que encore une fois il ya
tous ces bureaux vous savez jamais qui
fait quoi
mais en tout cas tous ceux qui sont au
contact des professionnels de santé
n'ont aucun pouvoir
et donc ce qui fait que vous avez un
gouffre entre deux mois personne je
crois pas que ça ne changera tant mieux
si je me trompe
en revanche la conséquence c'est qu'il
faut bien savoir ce qu'on donne à faire
à l'état donc surtout pas de pilotage
opérationnel de la santé il n'est pas
capable dans son organisation de le
faire donc le périmètre de l'état de
l'intervention de l'état doit être fait
aussi en fonction de cette question qui
est dit mais pourquoi c'est que
administratif parce que l'état français
est organisé comme ça je doute pas qu'on
puisse l'améliorer mais enfin c'est
quand même dans l'adn de l'état ça a un
certain nombre davantage mais en santé
ça fonctionne pas questions suivantes
prochaine question de colette de
montluçon comment expliquez vous que la
france n'ait pas été capable de produire
un vaccin en même temps que d'autres
pays c'est une question pour vous madame
la sénatrice
oui merci la france
oui mais certains français ont été
capables de produire et sont partis à
l'étranger pour le faire il ya un manque
on a manqué d'investissement
d'investissement les industriels ne sont
à l'étranger parce qu'ils ont trouvé des
fonds à l'étranger et en france on n'a
pas été capable de faire là de faire la
même chose donc on revient à l'enjeu de
la soulève la souveraineté sanitaires je
pense qu' il est grand temps de mettre
fin à ce problème là avec des indes et
des propositions très concrètes qui sont
faites sur le sur le fond
d'investissement sur le crédit impôt
recherche qu'il faut vraiment ouvrir on
a un outil qui marche et qui marche bien
ça n'arrive pas tous les jours mais on
le voit dans l'entreprise rencontre pas
un chef d'entreprise qui disent ce truc
ne marche pas au contraire le système
fonctionne bien il faut pouvoir là aussi
booster l'innovation accompagner la
recherche et laisser cet espace aux
chercheurs et c'est un professeur de
médecine région en fait c'est une
question très intéressante qui touche en
fait à tout la recherche en france
quelle que soit médical ou pas il ya un
principe de précaution qui est exacerbée
en france et qui est devenu un poids
dans son interprétation par son
interprétation
deuxièmement le barda nous on n'a pas de
barda bardasser ce fonds américains
c'est la proposition que nous faisons
été servi à ça troisièmement une fois
que vous avez atteint une certaine
taille comme industrie de recherche vous
avez du mal à vous développer
il nous manque en europe des fonds
capable d'investir dans le long terme et
des fonds à risques les capitaux à
risque et un marché unique des capitaux
que nous n'avons pas encore et puis il
ya enfin moi je crois beaucoup à ça je
pense que la france devient un pays où
la science disparaît c'est à dire que
nos élites n'apprennent plus la science
non plus d'esprit scientifique vous
rendez compte que 25 % simplement des
polytechniciens qui auparavant étaient
des gens pour que l'état fort mais pour
justement encadré au plan scientifique
le bon fonctionnement de la société
d'état 25% simplement du polytechnicien
qui sort de l'école
mettre au service de l'état donc on voit
bien qu'on a un sujet qui est sujet
d'une désertification
moi je suis pas embêté que les
chercheurs partent à l'étranger je suis
embêté qui reviennent pas et valbuena à
la société nantaise qui a développé un
vaccin
pourquoi est elle partie parce que quand
elle a demandé de l'aide on lui a
demandé de faire un dossier de trois
cents pages et les écossais l'ont dit
pas venez vite et on va faire les usines
chez vous chez nous et battant l'usiné
et en écosse prochaine question
dernière question de gènes de reims qui
vous est adressée monsieur le député que
faut-il faire pour développer la
télémédecine
je leur ai dit tout à l'heure je pense
que la télémédecine a pris beaucoup de
retard par rapport à nos à des voisins
étrangers que ce soit le canada que ce
soit la scandinavie haute dans tous ces
territoires où il ya des des surfaces
extraordinaire et où on est très très
loin des centres hospitaliers ou des
maisons médicales
donc en france on a des territoires qui
sont des territoires ruraux où on est
très loin des médecins d'où il n'y a pas
de médecin est donc la solution c'était
la télémédecine particulier la
téléconsultation comme la téléexpertise
comme la téléassistance la
téléassistance c'est pour éventuellement
pour le maintien à domicile où on peut
avoir un contact avec un médecin ou avec
une infirmière par internet on peut
également dans les ehpad avoir une
possibilité de transfert de données au
niveau de l'hôpital par rapport avec
internet
et puis au niveau de la téléconsultation
j'ai expliqué tout à l'heure que je suis
contre personnellement les cabines de
télémédecine qui sont totalement
impersonnel qui sont totalement non
humaine inhumaines et puisqu'il s'agit
de s'enfermer dans une cabine et puis
d'avoir
je ne sais quoi d des paroles qui vous
explique comment faire c'est quelque
chose d'inhumain
par contre qu'une infirmière blouses
blanches reçoivent un patient dans un
cabinet de consultation dans une petite
ville dans une commune qui est mis à
disposition par la mairie par exemple
l'infirmière et transmet avec des outils
connectés c'est au scope connecter les
oreilles la gorge le doppler etc
je passe sur tous les outils et qui
permet de transférer aux médecins en
immédiat immédiatement le lésé l'examen
médical et le médecin renvoi l'
ordonnance ainsi que la feuille youtube
sécurité sociale par le fax dans la
seconde qui suit est donc on a j'ai pu
obtenir par les huit cabinets de
téléconsultation effet dans le
territoire rural qui est le mien dans ma
circonscription et avoir a maintenant
fait plus de 6000 ou 7000 consultation
dans les six ou sept mois passés et ça
se multiplient régulièrement tant qu'il
ya pas de médecin c'est une solution de
secours
car philippe juvin pourra me dire qu'au
niveau des urgences
vous avez finalement au moins 40% de non
urgents et qui sont simplement des
appels à l'aide soit de renouvellement
d'ordonnancé soit de petits se peut de
petits bobos entre guillemets qui
peuvent dépendre simplement de la
téléconsultation donc on permet de
désengorger également les urgences du
centre hospitalier régional
oui je voulais dire que jean pierre door
m'a fait bénéficier à fait bénéficier ma
ville de
de la télémédecine vraiment très
connectée et franchement ça marche très
très bien bien écouter les ai pas rendu
compte de leur mêlée deux heures ont
finalement passé passé très vite sur ces
différents sujets alors je profite de
cette conclusion pour ce débat et cette
convention sur la santé pour vous dire
un mot plus plus générale du travail que
nous avons fait aux républicains depuis
plus d'1 plus d'un an maintenant
il ya eu un gros travail de fond et je
pense que de temps en temps il faut
aussi se féliciter de tout ce qui va
bien
c'est à dire la capacité que nous avons
eues à sur chacun des des sujets sur
lesquels nous avons travaillé à sortir
des propositions je pense que nous
sommes le seul parti si jean-pierre
voilà minutes
merci nous sommes le seul parti
politique aujourd'hui avoir été capable
de faire 5
je prends les conventions voyez sur le
handicap le réchauffement climatique
l'autorité de l'état la cohésion
nationale on abordait les sujets
immigration les sujets sécurité dans ce
domaine on a une convention travail
entreprises et pouvoirs d'un chat c'est
à dire que autour d'eux
ce qui est la rémunération du travail et
grandes idées gaullistes si elle est
c'est à dire qu'il n'ya pas d'un côté le
capital de l'autre côté les personnels
ou les travailleurs il faut bien
évidemment le monde dans l'entreprise
c'est celui qui rassemble et puis chacun
doit retrouver sa rémunération
on a parlé souveraineté numérique
on a fait une convention sur
alimentation et agriculture
l'alimentation saine à portée de tous
mais aussi un grand projet agricole a
restructuré à pouvoir relancer c'est à
dire que là aussi on est sur un sujet
stratégique l'efficacité de l'action
publique sert le rôle de l'état le rôle
des collectivités territoriales comment
on répartit les choses sur l'école et
les jeunes comment aujourd'hui l'école
doit amener à rentrer dans la vie
professionnelle le rôle de l'école ça
n'est pas de former pour former mais
c'est de répondre aujourd'hui un marché
qui est celui du travail
et puis de faire en sorte d'avoir cette
intégration qu'ils se fassent le plus
vite possible et d'avoir une formation
qui répondent et bien à la réalité du
marché de la demande qu'il ya sur le
travail
on a abordé le sujet des seniors mais au
sens large sous l'angle de la santé est
aussi sous l'angle du travail
sir comment on peut valoriser
aujourd'hui des des personnels qui est
qui ont qui passe puisque maintenant les
seniors facette plus en plus jeunes les
seniors on vit de plus en plus longtemps
on appelle seigneur de plus en plus de
plus en plus jeunes mais on a là des
puits d'expériences et de compétences
qui sont inutilisés air eau et déchets
c'était un sujet important lot ces
facteurs de vie bien évidemment mais
comment on travaille sur ce sujet
notamment sur l'agriculture où on a
besoin d'eau mais on a besoin aussi
d'avoir de l'eau de l'eau potable des
réseaux d'assainissement qui soient dans
de bonnes conditions pour tous
on était sur la souveraineté économique
puisque cette crise a bien montré que
dans un certain nombre de domaines on
vient de l'évoquer là sur la santé j'en
parlais sur l'agriculture mais aussi sur
l'énergie on aborder ce sujet des
risques de dépendance et de perte de
souveraineté dans ce domaine celui de la
santé aujourd'hui
surtout cela on était force de
proposition et donc de temps en temps
c'est un peu frustrant de lire quelques
éditoriaux mais quelle idée ils ont
quelques et bien écoutez je les invite
tout simplement à regarder les
propositions nous avons fait c'était un
vrai gros travail de terrain avec notre
service des études ici qui a travaillé
d'arrache-pied depuis 18 mois pour
sortir ces propositions et ça c'est pas
4 techno sur un coin de table
on l'a fait de la manière suivante en
mobilisant des élus territoriaux des
maires des conseillers départementaux
des conseillers régionaux
nos trois groupes parlementaires le
sénat l'assemblée le parlement européen
de faire venir des experts vous en avez
l'a7 à cette tribune mais c'est plus
d'une centaine d'experts qui nous ont
alimenté en propositions en réaction en
août challandes gens sur certaines des
propositions
tout ce travail de fond je pense
qu'aujourd'hui les républicains sont le
seul le seul parti à l'avoir fait ça a
été un gros travail
encore une fois de fond on a posé des
fondations je prends souvent cette image
qui est de dire vous savez avant de
réfléchir à la couleur des tuiles de la
maison ben faut d'abord être capable de
poser des fondations solides et en fête
avec tout ce travail c'est un socle
idéologique l'on a rebâti et on voit que
quand on fait ce travail est bien ma foi
de temps en temps c'est normal c'est la
vie politique c'est naturel chacun va
essayer de marquer sa spécificité sa
différence mais nous on a travaillé
différemment on a travaillé sur ce qui
nous rassemble est ce qui nous rassemble
et bien c'est l'addition de ces douze
conventions
là on a un socle idéologique à partir
duquel est bien au lendemain nos
élections territoriales aller voter on a
vraiment besoin d'une très forte
mobilisation
on a je crois de deux bons candidats qui
l'ont démontré dans leur réactivité dans
les communes mais qu'ils l'ont démontré
dans les départements dans les régions
et puis parce qu'ils étaient en place et
puis on a touché aujourd'hui qui
présente un projet pour cela mais c'est
tout cela qui va nous amener à préparer
la présidentielle parce que il ya un
socle idéologique qui a été rebâti par
ce travail qui a été réalisé et c'est là
dessus sur les élections territoriales
les maires on a gagné très largement les
municipales je ne doute pas qu'on
reporte une victoire au départemental et
aux régionales et puis ce socle de
propositions et c'est à partir de là on
va être effectivement en situation
d'aborder l'étape d'après la
présidentielle donc il faut les diffuser
et chacun d'entre nous et là je
m'adresse plus à nos militants il n'y a
pas que nos militants qui nous suivent
bien évidemment mais à nos militants on
a là un bon socle pour organiser des
réunions de terrain
et puis aux autres aussi de notre
challenge est de nous critiquer sur nos
propositions
c'est comme ça qu'on organise le débat
politique il s'organise de cette manière
là on a bâti le socle qui permet
d'organiser le débat
et puis ensuite eh bien il y aura les
deux ou trois grandes idées majeures qui
seront portées par notre notre candidat
à la présidentielle le moment venu et
vous allez voir dans les jours qui
viennent que le moment venu va en tout
cas la méthode pour y arriver
ce sera connue très très prochainement
puisque bien entendu
ce travail de fond sert une chose c'est
à créer et à bâtir un vrai projet
d'alternance avec un candidat de nos
couleurs qui le qui le portent donc
merci à vous tous et vous tout qui nous
suivez régulièrement certains d'entre
vous je sais ont suivi toutes les
conventions donc c'est vraiment
l'occasion de les remercier
chaleureusement remercié si les services
de la maison
les experts et puis tous nos tous nos
élus de terrain aux parlementaires qui
ont contribué à ce beau travail donc
charge à nous maintenant de savoir le
diffuser le plus largement possible
merci encore de nous avoir suivis
[Musique]